[Music]
and thank you representative uh soloway
for the periodic wellness
alert yesterday to encourage me to leave
in a timely manner that was much
appreciated i'm glad that you got home
safely mr chairman i was concerned
that's why i texted you and let you know
i was home safely
uh i enjoyed the exchange on imminence
versus imminence that's right that's
very important they mean different
things
i think that only the and me
know
the depth of the difference do you know
the difference between flammable and
inflammable
no there is no difference
um
both will burn
and we shouldn't address you as your
eminence
only that snowstorms are imminent
uh eminence is one title above mine so
all right we're all set to go when you
are representative pearson all right is
is the general public now available
uh yes they have been available
well i have to read the script
please as chairman of the house health
human services and elderly affairs
committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor and
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic and
in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee meeting
with hearings on bills and possibly
executive sessions as well
please note there is no physical
location for the members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to listen
contemporaneously
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
notice for this meeting
complies with the house rules and rsa
91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting
should call 271
or email h c
s
at leg leg dot
state
dot
nh
us
in the event the public as a whole
is unable to access the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled christina dyer committee
researcher will be the staff member
assisting us
please note that all votes are taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote
we will start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance
when each member states his or her
presence please also state whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting this is required under the
right to know law would the clerk please
call the roll and when your name is
good morning
representative marsh
we have him as absent correct yes he
will be coming in probably within an
hour or so okay thank you
um representative mcmahon
president
where are you
and anybody in the room
oh pardon me mr chairman um i'm at my
home office i am alone although uh my
wife and son are in other parts of the
house
representative nelson
i was here in brookfield and my wife's
in and out
representative acton
i am here in fremont and i'm alone in
the room but
my wife and daughter are in the house
representative gay
i'm here in salem in our office and my
representative cushman
i'm here and where and i'm alone in the
room but my family is in the house
uh representative folsom i'm here in my
home and i have a good looking guy
hanging out in the room next door
uh representative kelsey
i'm here in my home in bedford i'm alone
in the room but my daughter and husband
are in the house
representative king
i am here in milford and i'm alone in
this part of the house but my son is
upstairs doing studies today
representative kobalt
i am here in my home office in wilton
representative
i am in concord and i am a company
builded by a standard pool
representative may hold the safe car
down
i can see him and i'm reading his lips
so
i'm going to put him in as here uh
representative snow
yes i'm here in manchester in my
apartment my wife is also
present in the apartment but not right
around
representative schneider
yes jerry kanerk here i am here in
freedom um in my study my wife is
somewhere in the house now but will be
out tramping in the woods later
representative soloway
good morning all i am alone in my home
office in lee new hampshire
representative
hi i'm home alone in my home in
somersworth new hampshire
representative gutter upper
up him sorry i know it's
thank you so much good morning i'm in
my home in nashua my husband is
elsewhere in the house
okay thank you
uh representative shapiro
i am home in my office in keene alone
representative woods
uh yes i'm at home in my and in beau in
my study alone my wife is elsewhere in
the house
representative merchants
yes thanksgiving i'm home in claremont
and my wife is somewhere in the house
and representative pearson
i am home in my office in hampstead and
my wife is working hard in the other
room
thank you
before we begin the first hearing
i'm afraid i have to be the bearer of
bad news
and this is from the world of science
punxsutawney phil saw his shadow today
yes
no
you may have all of my snow
anyone who cheered
all right i am looking for my gavel
because that was a present oh it's here
and while you're doing that i'm going to
remind representative snow to mute
his thank you
got it
going to open the hearing on house bill
relative to food safety training for
child care centers and the chair
recognizes representative schmidt to
present the bill
oh that's monday
[Applause]
jeff you're not muted
yes i'm sorry
am i there i do not see representative
schmidt on my call-in list
i have her here she's ready oh okay
thank you and i am online
we can hear you representative schmidt
excellent good morning this this is the
most fun committee i've ever attended
you folks are you're awesome
um
thank you mr chairman and honored
members of this most hilarious committee
uh for the record my name is jan schmidt
and i represent nashua award one and i'm
here to um ask you to pass hb 617 a tiny
tiny little bill
last year a constituent asked to ask me
to help her with children and allergies
to keep them safer so between ols and us
we wrote a huge bill which would sweep
all we wanted into one bill
the education committee loved it but the
testimony from school nurses told us
that they already do all of this
uh so much is uh done in rules and of
course that's an appropriate place for
requirements like i've got listed on the
sheet i sent you
so it went to interim study and i heard
this from one of the subcommittee
members it was pointed out that
200 colon 44a covers everything in the
bill
except daycare and that should go to
health and human services there you go
so here we have hb617
any person employed by and serving food
in a licensed child care center shall
pass a food safety class meeting the
standards of the conference of food
protection
now i have an allergy to peppers and one
bite of the seeds are the skin and
within hours i've got this volcano
brewing inside but i know what i need to
know to avoid this
with no nurse on site children in
daycare rely on those adults caring for
them to ensure their safety this small
change would mean a big difference in
the confidence we have in the folks who
care for our smallest neighbors so i ask
you find
hb 617 ought to pass and i'll answer any
i see a hand from representative
natarapam
good morning representative schmidt good
morning neighbor hey how are you
um i was wondering does it specify how
many hours of training a
server would need to have
um i need to do more research on the
conference for
food protection but it's simply a safety
class
okay that sounds good we heard other
things about
hours of training for people who work
with people who have alzheimer's and you
know whatever and the hours of training
was kind of the issue so
um
a class in training okay thank you very
much thank you
my question representative weber
uh thank you mr chairman but uh i had
exactly the same question as
representative nutter upham so i will
lower my hand now
representative acton
uh good morning and thank you for taking
my um
question
uh representative schmidt um i've done
some work
matter of fact
excuse me i'm working with uh
representative mick williams
on a variety of reforms of of child
day care centers and one of the issues
that we found in the study that we did
where we had over 60 people show up and
testify
is that they're already required to have
18 ceus a year of training
and this is a huge burden especially on
the smaller
mom-and-pop style day care centers
that are out there so um i guess the
question is would this training
be
would would this
fill the requirement of the ceus and how
much does it cost the center to bring in
a course like this because it certainly
isn't free
i don't know but i think this this is
provided by the state
i think that you can take this class
i can do the research and find out for
you
okay we um
follow up yes follow-up thank you okay
um yeah
we should probably talk about this um
because we have a
we're having another study this time
with rebecca and i are doing a lot of
work
on trying to
get a hold of of the um
the
regulations on
child care centers we're losing for
every four that go under only one opens
and and it's a it's it's been made even
worse
in in this
time of coving so
um i was wondering if we could perhaps
maybe talk about this and try to fit it
all together because we have a piece of
legislation that's that's trying to cut
the amount of ceus down
to a more manageable level for these
centers
i think anytime we're talking about
regulations and making changes in them
the best thing obviously to do is look
at the whole picture
and if some are outdated if some are
duplicated if some are missing this is
the perfect opportunity to make sure
that the whole thing is made whole
that's an excellent idea thank you very
much representative
representative
because this is a follow-up to what we
just heard
i believe you told me 200 colon 41a
covers everything except
licensed child day care centers so the
question would be um
are they covered anywhere else in
statute and so therefore we are trying
to fill a gap or are they covered um we
just heard 18 hours
could you help me with that please as
far as as far as i know food safety for
children with allergies is not covered
anywhere
okay
follow up to myself um had you
considered then making this a
requirement for
everyone and not just licensed daycare
centers
um a requirement for someone who doesn't
go through a licensing procedure
might be very difficult to follow up on
okay
thank you
representative woods
uh thank you mr sharon um
question about and thank you for taking
my question representative schmidt
who is this conference for food
protection
i asked that because
i just ran across this as chair of the
workers comp commission
and who could provide certain services
turns out there was 436 credentialing
agencies in the u.s 136 of them in las
vegas
we were able to change that
to
just the american board of medical
specialties
um
to get uh have certain credentials
what
what is the status of this conference
for food protection how do they gain
this prominence in our proposed
legislation uh as as far as my research
has done it's it's a non-profit
organization that that's begun about 30
years ago and it's a formal process to
to follow food safety issues
if this is an inappropriate place to
make sure that the the class is done
that's fine as as i just said with uh
representative acton that if if
we could
make sure that the allergy safety is
covered under any current law for day
cares this would
incredibly incredibly make a difference
for some of the families i've spoken
with
follow up yes go ahead
um representative schmidt with after
this conference uh for food protection
has been completed is there any
follow-up um
um to to know whether this this has been
successful whether the education that
they get
is been
has done what it meant to accomplish uh
or is there no follow-up at all
i would imagine that there's no
follow-up on particularly on this and it
would be
i would imagine per child care center or
per anyone who serves food to the
children
so the follow-up would be every time
they have a new
um a new person working there they would
thank you mr chairman um
representative schmidt i am interested
in uh sort of maybe exploring some
unintended consequences one of the
um provisions of this bill sort of it
says anyone any person employed by and
serving food
it
perhaps sounds like a silly question but
is is there a definition around what it
what it means to serve food
obviously if i'm
if i'm dishing out food onto a plate
that's serving food
uh if i'm handing out snacks to students
or to children in this case
then maybe i'm probably serving food if
i'm handing them a
a meal or a snack that has been prepared
by a parent is that the same as serving
food so i guess my question is does this
become a de facto requirement that
everyone employed by the by the child
care center must uh must attend this
this class
but the bill itself does not
address that question
of definition
it does not
thank you representative merchant
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question representative
um
following up on the question about any
person
do
you expect all people to be
trained or having at least one person
within the facility trained so that
somebody there can recognize and deal
with it versus having everyone within
the facility of daycare being so trained
i would suggest that anybody who is
serving the children should have this
class anybody who is working there that
does not serve the children is not
follow up follow up
um and i'm drawing upon that as far as
like in the school system the nurse is
the one trying to deal with these kind
of issues
however the people serving the food in
the cafeteria may also not have the
training i don't know if that's the case
or not just trying to look at the scope
of the requirement and trying to be
ensure that we balance it between
the regulatory side of everyone versus
having someone there adequately trained
if if you look at what the school nurses
do presently within the rule not
necessarily within law but within the
rule that they must follow it's very
strict about what they're training and i
believe that anything that happens
within their purview has to be part of
this as well
i would say that yes
the people who create and serve meals to
children have to have
support and understanding of what
they're doing through the nurse
thank you
uh yes this is really interesting
because y'all are bringing up a lot of
really important ideas that need to be
clarified
um my i'm kind of interested in does
food safety how to handle food to keep
it safe
that also in this bill
the current rule
covers
recognizing allergies
are tracking allergies how to handle
allergies
for schools yes it does um
i have something from the nurses last
i i tried this bill as i said earlier
encompassing everything
and found out that the nurses already
take care of everything that they manage
um and i did hear back from them with
the full list of what they do but if you
check the rules on on school nurses and
allergies you'll find that it is
comprehensive
follow up yes
how do you find the rules to check
uh there's state rules on education and
nursing
it's it's the state's rules on this
yes ma'am it would just be really nice
to
know where that is because
uh if you could email us the location
it's at 200 colon 44a
i believe i put that in the document i
one more follow-up
i'm still asking really the same
question i mean the web page
to reach that because that's an rsa not
a rule
uh
i can send that to you after i do the
research
thank you so much for taking all of my
questions absolutely not a problem
representative nelson
yes thank you for taking my question
to uh child care facilities have nurses
normally
i do not believe so no
okay so that would not count on a
nurse being there to
help out on that my second question mr
chairman
would be
as a former school teacher
while i never served lunch
i have been a principal and in an
elementary school and you do find
yourself sometimes
filling in and serving
under special circumstances handed the
kid to lunch or mom brings it in and you
bring it to them because they forgot it
so
just curious about that
i'd ask your nurse if i were you i think
that's where um they they should make
sure that the entire school understands
the problems of food allergies and i
think at this point
almost all humans do understand how
deadly uh say a peanut allergy can be i
know that there's a the woman the
constituent of mine who actually asked
for this last year uh will be uh
speaking today she has some testimony
she has sent in i believe
and uh she has in-depth information on
this as her her child has suffering from
allergies
thank you
representative snow please unmute and
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative schmidt for taking my
question i assume that all child care
centers require the parents to fill out
a health history and answer certain
questions is one of the questions on
those forms
uh does the child have any food
allergies and to ask for other details
do you know if that's part of the
regular record
i would imagine that any child care
center that does not require this would
find themselves in in courts very
quickly this this is simply a matter of
protecting the business and all the
representative you mr chairman um
yeah i guess i wanted to better
understand the scope of the problem um
you know i i'm very aware of of the fact
that allergies can be
uh can be deadly in many cases and and
certainly are
a critical issue i guess i'm i'm trying
to understand
to what extent would this training
change the situation um you know if if
there if there's an awareness of that
already which i think has been pointed
out
um
does this really
change the situation or is it
essentially just telling people what
they what they already know in practice
every day that's that's uh that's my
concern is there any data on
sort of existing incidents and um
can you speak to how those might have
been um
avoided by uh by passing legislation
like this
and i don't mean to put it off but i
really think that my constituent has uh
the information that you're looking for
not my guessing but her knowing
representative schmidt so that i can
when it's time call on that constituent
uh what is your constituent's name
please oh you're going to ask me that
oh for heaven's sake
mr chairman i have hands up from the
audience from melissa clement and
heather gass as well as heather
thank you thank you uh then um
representative may i bring heather
gawson at this point
absolutely if if you're all done with me
that would be absolutely terrific you
guys are really inquiring minds i have
to say
um
[Music]
uh the chair recognizes heather agas to
oh i'm sorry
good good morning can you hear me
good morning heather
good morning
um
thank you chairman peterson um my name
is heather gast i'm a resident of
merrimack new hampshire
formerly of nashua new hampshire as
representative schmidt had mentioned
and i'd just like to thank the committee
for hearing my testimony here on hb 617
i've also emailed my written testimony
to the committee so please refer to that
for additional facts as well as some
data sources
and i'm here today because i have a two
and a half year old son with multiple
life-threatening food allergies and i
personally have experienced the severe
and life-threatening allergic reaction
known as anaphylaxis
i'm a working parent and i rely monday
through friday on child care and i've
found that the lack of food allergy and
anaphylaxis training as well as food
allergy care plan implementation to be
extremely troubling to say the least
um when you have a child with a
life-threatening food allergy seemingly
benign things such as milk eggs peanuts
or even sesame seeds could send your
child into anaphylaxis
my son was only seven months old he was
an infant when he experienced his first
allergic reaction at a child care center
right here in new hampshire
he actually did have an allergy action
plan in place from his physician because
he had already been diagnosed with a
peanut allergy
so an allergy action plan is something
that the physician will give you
that outlines what to do in an allergic
reaction it does not outline what needs
to be done day to day within a daycare
facility or child care program
to prevent an allergic reaction from
happening
so we made sure to instruct the child
care staff to only feed him food that
was brought in from home
and just as a note especially in smaller
child care facilities there is not
typically a cafeteria or a kitchen
the the teachers themselves are
preparing the meals and snacks for the
children and serving them
so we had told them not to give him
anything other than we brought in from
home
one day i came by the child care center
after lunch i noticed my son was having
an allergic reaction
none of the staff had noticed other than
that they remarked that he had seemed
pretty fussy at that time
immediately i saw that his mouth and
chin were covered in hives and so what i
did was i followed that out allergy
action plan that the staff did have with
them and i gave him zyrtec
that's the first step so thankfully he
was okay and thankfully i showed up when
i did because i caught the reaction in
time before it could have progressed
into anaphylaxis
so we did find out after questioning the
staff that he was fed another child's
yogurt by a staff member that was
covering a break in his classroom this
isn't unheard of i have a lot of
friends and family in this allergy
community and this happens more than you
you think
happens
i just want to be really clear here so
this reaction happened even though they
had been instructed only to give him
food and bottles from home
and he already had an allergy action and
plan in place for his other known
allergy
there was another occasion where two
staff members who were in charge of
caring for my son could not find his
epipens when i had asked about them
i actually had to instruct them on where
to look now this is something that all
staff is supposed to know at all times
where those medications are in case of
an emergency so you can imagine if my
son happened to have an allergic
reaction and these two staff members
were caring for him staff members that
again have been
through the ceus for um allergic
reactions cpr and first aid um they
could have been really bad they didn't
know where the pens were
i just want to mention that because
every second counts in an allergic
reaction um somebody can go from a minor
reaction to severe anaphylaxis within
minutes
so that's why it's really important to
know where those epipens are at all time
so as you can imagine all these events
had left me angry scared and anxious
every time i needed to leave my child in
someone else's care
so while this bill hb617 does take the
first steps of training child care staff
in food safety and things like
cross-contamination prevention i think
we really need to do more to protect our
food allergic children especially
infants and toddlers who cannot advocate
for themselves
i have read through the new hampshire
child care licensing rules
which are available on dhhs.nh.gov
many times and these are the rules that
govern
how child cares are licensed and the
rules that they need to follow in order
to keep that license active
there are a few key things i'd like to
point out that we really need to fix
with this and i'd like to if i can just
follow up on a couple of points from
some of the other representatives
um to follow up
excuse me for representative merchant
representative nelson um child care
centers are actually not required to
have a nurse on staff so this differs
from a k-12 situation
um the the staff is required to have cpr
and first aid training as well as a few
other ceus that are listed in that child
care document but just so you know that
they're not required to have a nurse on
staff and the majority of them do not
um to representative cole fault um every
single child care teacher that i've ever
seen serves food to children as you
mentioned it could be just serving a
snack it could be serving a full meal
but every single person that works with
the children in those facilities
do have interactions with food and
serving kids food so that's why i think
it's really important that
it's everybody that gets this training
to representative snow yes um they do
feel you do fill out a form when your
child does start at a new child care
center
they do ask for allergies but the
problem is that
excuse me
every day care or child care program
manage these things manage them manages
these things differently whether or not
they put a plan into place um
is is um different from
center to center
and um i'd just like to point out a
couple of holes that i've seen within
these child care licensing rules and why
i think this training
plus some anaphylaxis training is very
important
there's actually a powerpoint style
presentation that is part of those ceus
that um
everybody in the the daycare has to take
the problem with that it does not review
the various types of epinephrine auto
injectors and how to use them so there
are about six or seven on the market
some people are familiar with the
standard epipen but there are others
that have slightly different ways of
using them um so it's very important to
understand those differences and like i
mentioned the training that they
currently take does not cover all of
those
it also doesn't require a passing grade
so participants can click through the
slides of this training can complete the
training without reading the information
in comparison first aid and cpr training
actually requires hands-on experience
and a passing grade so anaphylaxis
training as it is a part of something
that is um
addressing a life-threatening situation
it really should be the same that they
um a couple of points about food allergy
and anaphylaxis training in general
that aren't covered by the current rules
um any food allergy and anaphylaxis
training really should train caregivers
and how to prevent exposure to food
allergens including food preparation
which this bill does cover
and how to recognize the symptoms of an
allergic reaction in anaphylaxis and
also how to treat allergic reactions
including one of any of the types of
injectable epinephrine that are
available
and then the other piece that i'd like
to mention here is with food allergy
care plan so a food allergy care plan is
something that's specific to each child
and should include steps to prevent
contact with food allergens so this is
different from the the plan that comes
from the doctor that tells you what to
do in case there's a reaction
so currently there is a vague guideline
in the rules
that they
that really needs to be expanded um
i think that we really need to have a
requirement that these plans are
reviewed and signed off by all staff
typically if they do create a plan it's
posted within the classroom but everyone
is not required to read it where that
comes into a problem is if there are
different child care staff members that
are covering breaks in other classrooms
if they have not been familiar with that
plan and they're serving somebody a
snack
they could potentially serve something
that the child is allergic to and and
that's exactly what happened to my son
also there's no predetermined format or
outline so we've had experience with a
few different child care centers and
we've had to provide something to them
each time so this is problem because
if there are multiple children in the
same classroom with food allergies they
could have different formats on the plan
and it just makes it that much harder
for the staff to kind of go through and
understand what they need to do to keep
their children safe
so um i really hope that the committee
here considers supporting hb 617 and
potentially amending it to include
required food allergy and anaphylaxis
training and requiring more
comprehensive food allergy care plans
for child care programs and i'm happy to
answer any questions that you may have
missed gas
do
child day care centers
do they have the requirement to have epi
or equivalent things on site
no not as a
as a standard requirement so the problem
with an epipen typically that i've seen
within legislation is that it does
require a prescription so typically what
happens is if your child has an allergy
the physician prescribes um the
epinephrine auto injector and then the
child has the care plan that's on file
with the daycare that um they have the
epipen kept at school and then they
could are at the daycare and then they
can use it that way but there is no
global requirement for stocking
epinephrine in child care centers in new
hampshire is there a requirement for the
stalking of such
devices if a child is present who would
need one
no that has to come from a
um prescription from a physician and
then be brought to the school that way
this the school themselves that the
child care center as far as i know
cannot request a uh prescription for
just any type of use of a epinephrine
auto injector
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
uh mrs goss for
taking my questions are you familiar
with this course conference for food
protection uh and as a second part to
that
had uh if you are familiar with it uh
had the staff attended such a class
would that have alleviated the issues
that you have uh identified relative to
your son
great question i have briefly looked
into this and i am by no means an expert
on it um i think that the training
potentially could have avoided my son
being served
a yogurt that was not his
i don't think that it would have helped
in the issue of having the staff
identify that my child was having an
allergic reaction
and also would not have helped with the
issue of the other two staff members not
knowing where those epi pens were um i
do think that the bill is important to
show um cross-contamination and make
sure that that people understand that
and that's what that training would
i didn't have my hand up i don't know if
that's still from before it is from
before uh if you have had your hand up
and you have asked your question please
take your hand down
thank you thank you mr chairman my
question would be
bus drivers some i don't know if
preschool kids get bust or not but if
they go to kindergarten
they are bust do bus drivers have to
take some of this uh a course like this
i mean a bus driver i know will give out
things for christmas it may put the kids
a little candy or something like that
that's a great question um i as far as i
know and in my experience i have not
come across a child care center that um
uses buses i know in k through 12 we
this issue actually came up last year
with the education committee with the
previous bill that representative
schmidt had mentioned that tried to
cover that and no in new hampshire
currently bus drivers for k-12 are not
required to
have any type of allergy and anaphylaxis
training or epipen training
thank you
thank you mr chairman and i'm sorry that
i'm not always polite i forget
um
because i also had a child with many
many food allergies i'm really sensitive
to your problem
uh and i'm thinking all these additions
to the rules sound really good the
education especially
and i'd like to suggest too that there
be something children can wear
that says what they're allergic to
because when people are taking care of
multiple children obviously
they can be distracted
and forget which child is allergic to
which
so i'm just thinking something
appropriate that they could wear
on top of their clothes or pinned to
their clothes that wouldn't be a problem
for another reason
might be a life-saving thing
just to catch people's attention that
they if they don't know what that child
is allergic to it's a reminder you
better check
and also be looking at the child to see
representative
chairman pearson do you mind if i
um answer that or please do comment on
that um i think that's a great idea
that's something that personally we've
implemented my son wears a little yellow
band that shows what he's allergic to um
it's definitely at this point not a
requirement and i think that would be a
great addition to the food allergy care
plan as something that the schools could
have in place
make sure that everybody knows what the
child is allergic to
um ms gas might that be an optional
thing because i could think of scenarios
where a child wearing such an indicator
could subject the child to some taunting
from other students
so might that be something to be
considered on a case-by-case basis
absolutely and i i think just with my
experience with other um parents some
parents are more sensitive about it than
others i would say the majority is more
concerned for the child's safety um
especially when they're in the infinite
toddler stage where the the bullying and
the comments may not be an issue but i
absolutely would agree with you that
that should probably be something that
would be optional
i do not have a question
please take your hand down okay
thank you and i'm going to call on
representative merchant but i don't see
him so i think that's a leftover hand
thank you mr chairman and i i
miss goss i wouldn't have
normally asked this of a member of the
public but you seem to be very familiar
with our licensing rules
of necessity and for that we thank you
for your expertise
i'm going to put this in the form of a
question
is it not true that there's a difference
between the statute the law that we are
looking at today
which perhaps ought to specify the broad
areas
that we need rules on
like
food safety
allergy recognition
um
you know safety plans that sort of thing
which could be put in the rule
and the specifics of
what is required for daycare which ought
to be done by rulemaking which is not
which is for the department and not for
us is that is that a reasonable
separation of
um
sort of
separation of responsibilities
yes i would agree with that um i would
also mention that i have reached out to
um dhhs to the child licensing
coordinator a few times with my
questions and and sometimes the answers
that i've received back
kind of led me to believe that they are
not fully familiar with some of these
struggles that were having
so i think
really understanding which side this
falls on whether it be on the
legislative side or the rule side is
definitely
you know something to to be determined
and i definitely don't have the answer
fully to that yes
mr chairman could i could i just make a
statement to the committee uh if you
would permit me well that was a well
what you just said was actually a
question so that was a lead-in i know
but but
now i'm going to do something that's
normally inappropriate
um
the issue is that
they cannot make rules unless we pass a
statute
and so for those who are new to the
statutory and rule making process
the department can't make any rules
unless they are authorized to
by statute so if we pass a statute that
authorizes them to make rules in this
area then they must make the rules but
without a statute passed by us they
cannot make rules and i just wanted to
make sure that everybody on the
committee understood that and understood
the difference
but
it seems to me that we as a committee
don't need to get down into the weeds of
exactly what the regulations are
we just need to figure out what needs to
be permitted
and then leave it to the department and
i thought that might
focus us a little bit more
representative that that's very very
helpful and one of the reasons one of
the reasons we do that is because
sometimes the details change
and therefore we would have to go
through a long process to change the law
but if we have the broad tenants in
place then the rules may be amended very
quickly within the department so
i i think as we
eventually come to closure on this bill
we would want to
broaden it but only in these general
terms thank you for that very much and
when the parties flip and you're the
chair again and i'm just a guy i will
remember that occasionally it doesn't
have to be a question thank you for the
president
representative woods
uh thank you mr chair and uh thank you
again uh uh ms goss for taking my
question
um would someone be able to send us a
syllabus on this uh
conference for a food protection course
so we have some ideas uh
i think that would be helpful to
understand exactly what is the content
and as a sidebar to that
i
heard you and if you could clarify you
said something about not needing a
passing grade
was that relative to this particular
course or something else that was
relative to a different course so there
is what they call a ceu
for food allergy training that the
daycare staff is required to take and it
is basically just a click-through power
point um i've actually gone through it
just to to see what it was myself and
technically you can click through it
without actually reading the slides and
it will mark that you have completed it
that is in comparison to a cpr first aid
class which requires a passing grade in
order to be certified
um as far as your question regarding um
the
the um the the actual training um i can
do some additional research into seeing
if we can get that for you and i think
um also representative schmidt could do
that for us as well
yes i just have it real quick and follow
up on what was just said a moment ago
rather than getting down in the weeds
about which uh course and putting that
into statute uh could we not just give
the authority to dhhs and rule making to
approve an appropriate course and not
prescribe that here because that might
change this organization may go out of
business would that also be and i'm
asking this maybe more as a question to
the chair would that be an acceptable
way to handle this
let me
hold off a little bit about going
forward but i think that's a great
suggestion thank you welcome back
representative marsh you're recognized
to speak
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
state for the record that i am present
and home alone in my home office in
brookfield so that we are compliant with
91a thank you sir
anyone else with a question for ms gas
or representative schmidt
because we have a few members of the
seeing none thank you both very much
thank you
and the chair recognizes melissa clement
good morning mr chair um
good morning and members of the
committee i'm melissa clement i'm
actually the chief of the child care
licensing unit at health and human
services so i think i can help address
some of the issues that have come up and
provide some clarity there and i'll
answer any additional questions that you
may have as well
for child care licensing rules we do
require that any staff who are
responsible for supervision of children
or being used to meet child staff to
child ratios they do have to complete a
training on the prevention of in
response to emergencies due to food and
other allergic reactions so we do have
that training i understand that miss gas
spoke to
i'm not sure which training she took the
department allows trainings in that
broad topic we
provide through the bureau of child
development and head start collaboration
a free training from pro solutions that
addresses that topic and you need to
have at least a passing score of 80
percent in order to
mark that as complete so all you you're
able to go through the course you're
able to repeat the sections where you
didn't get the questions correct and
once you get an eighty percent you have
you have passed that ceu and you get the
um those training hours
in addition our rules address
um
underneath our prevention and management
of injuries and emergency section
um h e
c 4 0 0 2
f
um
each child who has a food allergy or
other allergy that results in a serious
reaction
shall have a written care plan that
includes the instructions regarding the
foods or other allergens with the child
is allergic to and the steps to be taken
to avoid them
a detailed treatment plan to be
implemented in the event of an allergic
reaction including the names doses and
methods of prompt administration of any
medications
and specific symptoms that would
indicate the need to administer one or
more medications
and then at least one child care
personnel supervising a child with an
allergy care plan shall have completed
that training because you do have 90
days to complete the training so we also
take the additional step that if it's a
new staff you still have to ensure that
any staff with a child with an allergic
care plan has taken the training
so there isn't anyone there who's not
trained and then each child's care plan
shall be posted prominently in the
child's classroom and whenever the child
may come in contact with the allergen
with permission from the parent
so those are the steps that we've taken
in our rules currently to make sure that
children with allergies are identified
that the staff understand what it is
they need to do and how they need to
follow through and that they have to
have training and also with that they
also have to have first aid and cpr
certification as well that's a
requirement for all staff and child care
programs
underneath our statute
rsa
170e-11 which is our rulemaking statute
under the provision of 1e
it allows for provisions of food
clothing educational opportunities
program equipment and individual
supplies to assure the health and the
physical and mental development of
children serve so that is the
rule-making statute that we use when
we're talking when we're addressing the
needs of children and their health needs
and with that i'll turn it back over
to you guys and i'll answer any
additional questions you have
i have a question for you miss clement
um
given what you've said
is this bill necessary
and there's a follow-up to that let's
start with that is this bill necessary
then
i believe that when we look at our rules
there's always room for improvement i
don't
i think that we've addressed them in our
rules and we can certainly tweak the
rules that we have but i welcome any
suggestions from the committee to make
sure that the children are safe
then my follow-up would be
based on previous testimony i believe
from representative weber
are there statutory
provisions that you need or would like
or both
to help you in areas of rulemaking
where the statute is presently silent
um at least in regards to food allergies
i don't believe the statute is silent i
believe we have the statutory
requirements we need in order to address
so while there's always room for
improvement you seem your testimony
seems to answer the concerns that people
have brought would you say
i believe that we have based on the
testimony i heard today i think we have
sufficient rules to address the concerns
i certainly
um want the any parents to reach out to
us if they've had a concern in their
child care program so that we can
address those specifically with each
child care program um there's always
unfortunately going to be times when a
program may not be sufficiently aware of
what it is they need to do or you know
there's ways that we can assist the
individual programs but i think broadly
our rules
are there to address those concerns
thank you mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question
i'd like to ask the woman from dhhs
whose name i didn't catch
but uh
maybe you could give me that too but
you said that the the
plan the care plan for responding to
somebody who has an allergic reaction
you need to write that plan up once the
child has had
an adverse reaction to some food product
does that mean you don't have a care
plan for somebody who the parents report
a food allergy but you don't really
they're not required to do the plan
until it happens at school or is the way
that thing is worded it just says if
they've ever had
a food
allergic reaction either at home in the
community or at the daycare that this
action plan gets developed
thank you clearly on the question
yes um thank you representative snow um
and my name is melissa clement i'm the
chief of the child care licensing unit
so the rule i read through them pretty
quickly but the way the rule is written
it says each child with a food allergy
or other allergy so
where
you can't write a care plan if analogy
hasn't yet been identified but that can
be identified before they enter the
child care program it doesn't need to
happen at the program thank you very
much
i'm going to bring uh heather gas back
she has her hand up i think she may be
wishing to speak to the question that
was posed heather gass
i just did want to point out maybe a
couple issues here and maybe melissa
you'd be able to clarify so to that
previous question about addressing
children um who already have an allergy
and having a care plan for that i guess
i would i would point out that one of
the holes is that especially in my
child's case he had a reaction to
something that he had never had before
um so and i've seen this with again with
friends and family where children have
their first allergic reaction within the
child care program and there's no
current plan within the rules to address
that
other than the first aid and cpr
training and that initial food allergy
training
thank
you the chair would now like to
recognize rosemary run who has her hand
up
good morning can everyone hear me okay
yes we can
thank you for the record my name is
representative rosemary rung i represent
merrimack which is hillsboro 21.
i became quite knowledgeable about the
whole area of food allergies about a
year and a half ago
when a constituent asked if i would
pursue legislation to expand food
allergy awareness training
to restaurants that fall outside the
jurisdiction of the department of health
and human services
many communities in new hampshire
are licensed by the state but there are
very many that are only licensed and
inspected by their local jurisdictions
so they are exempt from following the
new hampshire food code
now back in 19
back in 2017 the u.s changed their food
code to require
restaurants to have a food safety
manager on site at all time
new hampshire adopted the u.s food code
that same year
and put into their rules which is hep
2300 the requirement of food safety
managers for new hampshire restaurants
under new hampshire state jurisdiction
my bill would have expanded that
requirement to restaurants that are else
are only in local jurisdictions
that law was titled rachel hunger law
after the young female student at unh
who died from an anaphylactic reaction
at a local durham restaurant
it was a chinese restaurant she had
frequented often but they had changed
their recipe for egg rolls unbeknownst
to her which now included peanut paste
and she was allergic to peanuts
so this bill um passed the committee and
it went to commerce it passed the house
on a voice vote but it got hung up in
the senate due to coven delays
that bill has now been reintroduced and
i'll be testifying in front of commerce
at a at a date soon to come
the director representative
representative this bill is about child
care licensing and we're already way
behind
okay me hurry up
okay but in the course of that research
i learned that four to eight percent of
children in the us suffer from food
allergies and that number is going up
um
the training that they would be able to
the child care workers would be able to
um have is um also the same training
that's now being offered and extended
through restaurants throughout new
hampshire
and it's it's under a company called
servsafe and it's one of the few uh
training
training modules that
um is recognized by the department of
health and human services for restaurant
licensing it takes about one it could be
any it could be an eight-day an
eight-hour module or sixteen hour module
there are three different types there's
in-class virtual self-study
i think if this bill passes there would
be a lot of synergy between offering
this training to
child care workers along with the new
hampshire restaurant and lodging
association who drives a lot of the
training management for um their members
in the state
um and it's about 200
uh to take it that and that's for the
highest level of training there's
there's different levels food safety
manager food handler
and goes on but
i as a co-sponsor of this bill i support
it 100
i think that it fills in the gap between
um actually giving a child food but then
preparing the food and recognizing those
things which can set off an animal
phylactic reaction
often it's very easy to let's say
substitute flour for corn starch or a
product a packaged pancake mix for
instance that may have dried egg solids
in it so the training enables people to
be able to recognize sources of
allergens and how they interact
but thank you very much for this
opportunity
thank you representative uh seeing
there's no more hands up either
on the
panelists or under the attendees
i'm going to close the hearing
on house bill 617 and i'm going to make
a suggestion
many of us
do not want unnecessary regulations
however i think many of us are quite
aware that some regulations need to be
made
and so the question is is this bill
necessary as it is
or are there a few things that should be
in statute that aren't whereby we may
help dhhs to do their work and so what
i'm going to suggest representative
schmidt thank you so much for raising
this issue uh i have personal
uh allergies
and experience with anaphylaxis i have
dear friends who are of tender age who
have the same
and so i am very aware of the situation
so what i'm going to ask representative
schmidt is you have a
much further conversation with melissa
clement from
dhhs
find out where the gaps are as the
department sees them as you see them and
perhaps come back to us either
suggesting the bill goes forward as
you've given it to us
or sig or perhaps withdraw it or ask us
to i to tell it or third come back with
an amendment that would round out
everything we've discussed today and
certainly anybody here is free to call
you
with their input
this would normally be the kind of thing
we would have a nice work session but
we're coming up on crossover deadlines
fairly quickly we have a lot of bills
and we don't have a lot of available
computer time so we're getting the word
minimize work sessions subcommittees so
representative schmidt i'm going to
suggest that to you
and with that the hearing is closed and
we will move on
to
our
next item
and this should take a while
uh gavel
i open the hearing now on
house bill
relative to reimbursement for
telemedicine
and i'm going to call on representative
jess edwards from finance division three
and an alumnus of the greatest committee
in the house both to introduce the bill
and also speak
to the amendment
and this is important
because we have gotten i think this is a
technical term
bazillions
of emails about certain aspects of the
bill as originally submitted that the
amendment may address
so representative edwards would you
please introduce your bill and speak to
the amendment
i will uh thank you mr chairman um
good morning to the members of hhsea
uh i'm uh representative jess edwards
representing uh auburn
i i think for this conversation i i need
to um
remind some of you and tell some of you
about my background i've been a
healthcare informaticist for a couple
decades
um i was a when i was a clinical manager
at west virginia university i
implemented teleradiology there that was
a pretty early
implementation for the era
from there i moved to become the deputy
program manager of the telemedicine test
bed in the mid 90s and i was an
instructor at georgetown university
during that time frame
i
wrote a textbook chapter on military
telemedicine along with several articles
and spoke at many national conferences
on the subject
from there i spent two decades as a
product manager
meeting customer needs with digital
imaging so i worked with
engineers and technologists to put
together emerging solutions to meet
clinical needs
then as a member of the house i was in
2018 a member of the telemedicine
healthcare reimbursement for
telemedicine telehealth study committee
uh that was chaired by senator uh
jay kahn
and uh we found some interesting things
in that study that we we did and
it's been published it showed
um what we what we learned was that
medicaid
was lagging
way behind the commercial insurers for
covering telemedicine and and certainly
if they weren't covering it they weren't
reimbursing well
so senator khan and i with others
introduced legislation to have medicaid
catch up to the insurance companies so
hey there's emerging clinical practice
out there that medicaid is not up to
speed on so so let's let's get going
well
then uh something funny happened uh we
had the uh and i don't mean funny as in
humorous but
uh quirky we had a uh a pandemic
that motivated on the 18th of march of
2020 the governor to issue an executive
order
that said
we were in a state of crisis and that we
needed to
preserve our health care system
and a key strategy for doing that was to
find ways in a crisis mode
of keeping patients out physically from
clinical settings
and so
the governor's team opened up the
spigots
and said
go forth
do as much telemedicine as you can
telemedicine from this point on shall
include audio only so telephone calls
can be reimbursed the same
must be reimbursed the same or better
than in-person care
so so clearly the pandemic response was
you know let's not worry about the
fiscal notes let's not worry about the
monetary impacts we have to preserve our
health care system
have patients get their care without
having to come into the facilities
so it really made a lot of sense
so
with this
and i'm going to really talk about the
amendment because the bill i i think in
retrospect with all the feedback i've
gotten i've gotten half a bazillion
uh uh comments on it the underlying bill
itself was kind of a mess
um
so i submitted an amendment that is
really pretty clean what it what it does
the state is going to become agnostic
on what the reimbursement rates ought to
be for in-person care
versus
um telemedicine
um that that we are not going to be in
the role of setting or fixing prices
um it it it weights
for 180 days after the executive order
has expired
uh i picked the 180 days
to give
clinic clinicians an opportunity
to transition their patients from
the kind of care they've been getting
for the last year and more by the time
this is over
to
what they consider the appropriate
standards of clinical care in the
aftermath of the pandemic ceasing
so for all the people who are concerned
we can't do this in a pandemic i agree
we're not going to do this in a pandemic
for those of you with eagle eyes
and who are looking at
the amendment
2021-0195
hotel
if you look down under applicability
it it it does a pretty good the ols
people heard me they said we're going to
make this effective after
the state of emergency is over
but where there was
a mess up is
she did not put in the 180 day
transition
so i've contacted her courtney
s schaab i think her name is
yeah and she recognizes
um that the 180 days
went missing
from the amendment so so i i apologize
to the committee there's an amendment to
the amendment
um coming but but so the the the
two things it does and the one thing it
does not do
is the two things it does is uh it it
will wait it waits until after the state
of emergency is over and it creates uh a
grace period i think of 180 days if the
committee thinks it should be a
different number that's fine
and also it breaks the connection
between
the requirement the mandate to reimburse
telemedicine at the same or higher rate
than they do in person care
that's that's a that's an artificial
edict
that makes sense and a crisis
but does not make long-term
sense
and and and then the the thing that this
does not do
is this bill does not in any way
step on the special provisions that we
need to deal with the pandemic
we we take a breathing period after the
pandemic before this bill
takes effect so for those concerned
about the pandemic i assure you this
bill has nothing
to do with that
um
and and because i've gotten a whole lot
of
messages
saying that i that i i'm being
short-sighted i want to assure people
that i'm actually being very
long-sighted
my vision of telemedicine
uh really started in the 1960s with reba
ben scooter and cecil whitson
who i got to know as as a young teenager
um and i got to understand the
telemedicine program that they put in
place with the nebraska psychiatric
institute
between omaha and norfolk
i i i know from then and from reading
about it
that that
that the technology
hadn't really been invented just a year
earlier it was a t's invention of some
critical
components that even made it possible
and so
so the university of nebraska medical
center got interested in telemedicine
even though it cost a bazillion dollars
more than in-person care because they
had a clinical research component to it
but if you go back in time telemedicine
has been
really really expensive and the price
points are coming down
rapidly
um i think it's analogous to a lot of
the arguments people used to have
about
canals and railroads
they were both ways to transport
uh goods from supply centers to
population centers
uh had
uh and there was a great deal of
competition the government tended to
favor canals private industry tended to
pro uh favor railroads
uh it's this bill where um we've said
that the price mechanism between
telemedicine and in-person care
is sore like if at that time when canals
and railroads were finding their their
place in our transportation network that
somebody had issued an edict that said
one pound of coal
shall
be charged the same amount for transport
regardless of the
method of conveyance
representative representative edwards uh
we're way behind in our schedule would
you please focus on just the high points
without the history as much as i love
history and wrap it up thank you
mr chairman the reason
yes sir i will but the reason i'm
belaboring it
is because um
disconnecting or freeing up the pricing
mechanism is the core of this bill
and there will be people on the
committee
who
will
want to keep the pricing mechanism
locked up
to ensure telemedicine and in-person
care
forever
more
shall be
mandated in the statute as it is today
and and it's those people i'm trying to
speak to to say
please think of this differently than
what you have been this is this the
pricing mechanism is essential to
sending
market signals to investors and and
others
to because we have an entire
re-engineering of the health care system
in front of us
we have rapidly emerging technology
that's going to give us a tremendous
number of options we've not had
so so i'll skip down um at your request
let me skip down to
a key part of this um and i you may want
to take a look at my testimony i sent it
in last night it hopefully it reads like
an interesting
academic paper
but one of the things i wanted to point
out
is that
their
technology changes things initially by
substituting one approach for another
that's where we're at now with
telemedicine instead of traveling we're
in instead of doing uh traveling to the
in-person care we can virtually travel
well what's going to happen
as this evolves is there's going to be a
period of time where uh increased
coordination because of the technology
is in place will start to happen so
you'll start to see people who worry
about
coordinating social determinants of
health for example be able to do
person-centered care much more
effectively they'll be enhanced
abilities to communicate with people
throughout the community and throughout
the state that's because the technology
will begin to be more familiar and be
more leveraged
what what the third order effect is is
when we totally create new new methods
of providing clinical care
so like with the advancements in
wearable biotech
uh and ubiquitous communications
uh it's it's what what we're going to
see in a few years
um is
the constant transmittal of your
personal medical data to a storage
center where there will be artificial
intelligence applying smart algorithms
to determine whether or not the the
person is has remained within specs
if you get thrown out of
uh standards
you go from being a person to a patient
the the the the watch can send an alert
saying hey you need to go see somebody
now
we'll be able to tie that to gps we'll
be able to tie that to scheduling
software and to
geo locators
to say you need to go see someone now
and oh by the way there's a person four
blocks away from here and they're
available right now
representative edwards i'm going to cut
you off right now we have in this
committee as you should know enough
people for me to staff a medical center
a counseling center and a pharmacy so
i'm going to suggest now that they ask
you questions because a lot of what
you're saying most of us know very well
from living it
i guess the space bar didn't work can
you hear me now yes we can
um thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative edwards for taking my
question
um it seems to me like part of um
your agenda here is not to pick winners
and losers and to be
um to be open to which services are
more
efficient and effective and yet
your amendment
video telehealth will be covered but
audio will not necessarily be covered
now we have received many many many many
emails from lots of people but i think a
majority of them have been from
substance use disorder treaters and
mental health clinicians
yes sir so if i may are you looking at
uh the amendment
0195 hotel
i think i am i am look at look at line
where
uh line 14 is it says audio and it
deletes the reference to audio only
i i have
left audio only
as an option
uh where the government doesn't need to
take a position on when audio only
is good clinical care right like for
example i have diabetes i had a phone
call where the provider went over my
readings with me and we talked about it
she determined whether or not i needed a
change in medication
all of that was good clinical practice
over the phone
but if i had needed to see my
ophthalmologist to determine you know
progress of my eye surgery
i probably would have had to go in
person so some things are open to
telephone calls or some things or not
this bill stays neutral it stays out of
the discussion
follow-up representative shapiro
follow-up
well i haven't asked my question yet
um it appears to me that um audio is an
option
but it's not one that's mandated
and i'm wondering
and and
video and audio are mandated so my
question really is
um do you have research do you have data
that says that
audio only is less effective than audio
video
and do you also have research which
might
talk about
the number of people that have been able
to access services through audio only
that would not be able to if there was
not audio only mandated
i i i'll address that but i first need
to just say that we have an
interpretation difference i i think
lines 13
through 15 do the opposite of what you
suggest i think it includes audio only
as a reimbursable uh option
uh what what this bill is trying to do
is to get out of the the micro
management of exactly which clinical
services can be done over the phone and
which ones cannot
i i i think you would agree with me
that there are examples that you and i
can think of right now where telephone
only is okay
but there are other examples where
telephone only doesn't
do it it does it's not adequate clinical
care
so so
it's not up for us
to mandate reimbursement in a situation
where the clinical effectiveness can
vary between
different
clinical requirements
so your your other question about am i
familiar with research
well i know that clinical efficacy
research research in various aspects of
telemedicine
uh have been taking place for 20 30
years so so depending on on what
specific clinical subspecialty
you're looking at
you would have to burrow into
the available research to see whether or
not that particular clinical question
has been
asked
um
i will i will
defer to the next questioner
sorry about that thank you mr chair
thank you representative edwards
um i just want to clarify something to
make sure i'm seeing this properly the
concern that was raised in most of the
people that contacted me through email
was that they felt they would be limited
to audio
or video only
however it reads now in your amendment
that
the uh coverage will be for
all modes of telehealth including video
and audio
and other electronic media
so uh that whole concept of them having
to have video i'm
see i'm reading that that has been taken
out
and dismissed and that people will now
be able to use just audio
that that is exactly my intent
representative folsom i i did get a lot
of feedback and and it was it was pretty
clear that the audio only issue was uh
causing a great disturbance and so i've
gotten the government out of making
those
incremental judgment calls that's up to
the clinical efficacy research and
decisions by others
this the space bar didn't work
um
thank you mr chairman
representative edwards i'm going to give
you an um a situation i encountered and
you can help me understand how this bill
would impact the two different
situations
uh i
went to see a pulmonologist
i believe that's the term
and the first time i saw him was an in
in-person visit
and so i understand that the charges
would be for an in-person visit
the second time i went to see him
the coped rules were in place and i was
um and i went to
the
office i was brought to a tour a
treatment room
and um
where the where the nurse took my weight
and uh and blood pressure
and then told me to wait for the phone
to ring
where i took i answered the phone it was
my physician we had a conversation
and when the
conversation was done
they let me leave the building
he charged me for an office visit
another month or so later
i had
a
telemedicine call
video and and voice over my telephone
to ask basically the same questions i
had when i was when i was at his
practice
during my second visit so
would all three of those situations be
charged the same
under this under your bill
so so thank you for the question and i
hope you're you're feeling strong and
robust uh
and the pulmonologist is helping you
with all of that i have asthma by the
way
so uh i would say that it depends on the
time frame we're talking about
if we're talking about the time frame
that begins 180 days after
the the eo is uh vacated or or expired
then
um the ability to charge and be
reimbursed
by the insurance carriers would be based
on their independent assessment on
whether or not
the the visit met clinical efficacy
standards
and not being a pulmonologist but kind
of imagining what sort of
questions you were being asked
it would just seem to me that the
pulmonologist perceived
that he or she was able to provide you
good care
through video conferencing without you
physically having to travel for a
weigh-in
and uh i i think i think that would be
fine i think reimbursement for that is
great i
i i want to see healthcare much like the
way we do banking these days where
it's all it we do far more of it online
uh
at midnight than we do
in person at the bank itself so
so i would i would think that
what this bill says is we don't tell the
insurance carriers what to do
we just say here's an issue
you guys work it out
and and i think i think
that sort of market mechanism is what's
going to
rationalize the system the best over the
long term does that answer your question
um
not quite could i follow up you may
in both the the second and my third
visit um
both of those situations were only
voice conversation
in the in-office visit i didn't even
have a video with my physician
my last visit i actually had a video
so
my in-office visit i am assuming would
be
would be paid by the insurance company
for an in-office visit the third
situation with essentially the same
questions but over my telephone
were
essentially the same
but i was out of the office
so you're telling me i would have after
this
bill goes into place 180 days after the
the eo
that then i'm at the mercy of my
insurance company as to whether i would
get reimbursed at the office rate or not
is that is that what i'm hearing
well representative cannon that's
probably what you're hearing that that's
not what i'm trying to say though uh i i
don't think insurance companies are
merciless so i wouldn't use the term at
the insurance companies mercy i do i i
would just uh
remind you of what the 2018 telemedicine
study found which was that commercial
insurance carriers were doing a vastly
better job of covering and paying for
telemedicine than the state was
and that our goal in 2018 was to get the
state to catch up the government was the
problem and that was just two years ago
and so i think insurance companies
have a built-in incentive to build the
right health care system to take care of
patients and and so they're looking at
cost access and and quality every bit as
much as any other
player so i don't i
i only just would take issue with the
terminology
but but the intent is
this would get the government out of
that decision it would allow the
insurance companies to act like
a free party in the health care system
thank you representative
thank you mr chair uh representative
edwards i just have a question there's a
phrase you used three times because of
the three different types of coverages
and uh that is where you refer to a uh
criteria of good clinical methodologies
based on research or accepted practice
so i was curious
you alluded to it a little bit before
but do we have this research and if so
can you give reference to that research
and could you perhaps clarify who makes
the decision
regarding which
research or practice
i okay your
um
thank you representative kenner i would
say
that the research in telemedicine
is much like the research in any
clinical subspecialty
there is not
just one
source one database where the research
gets filed and gets sent
there's just there's not one
arbiter of all known research
in any of the clinical subspecialties
there are
associations
uh that that tend to to be expert there
are telemedicine associations that one
can join to where
they they
they can obtain
um
regular
newsletters and the like of telling them
what's going on in
in telemedicine research so it's
telemedicine is as viable an academic
research area
as any of our
clinical sub-specialties in my view at
least that's the way it was you know
when we were the telemedicine test bed
there was research being done in hawaii
medical college of georgia
university of virginia
it's just being done
in a highly distributed manner like all
academic medicine
um
and i forget the second part of your
question
look
you may follow up with that yes well
that is exactly my question because
there is no one standard people will
disagree so my question is who
makes that decision because somebody has
to actually make that decision to
implement these
rules that you're kind of discussing
here
who has that power because that's not
okay so back in the olden days when um i
was representing positron emission
tomography
and how we would apply pat to various
clinical scenarios
uh we would we would do studies
uh we would have our academic nuclear
medicine people look at it if if we
determined it was efficacious
i was the one that would go to the blue
crosses and blue shields and say
this is the care we're providing
you're not reimbursing us for this
here's our medical research would you
please uh begin to reimburse us for this
because this is better than the uh
alternatives
and the blue cross and blue shield as a
as an independent payer would would
consider what was being said and and
would uh
decide whether or not to reimburse us
uh fortunately we ended up getting a lot
of yeses and pet today is an extremely
viable part of nuclear medicine
but it wasn't always that way
and and so that those same sorts of
dialogues with payers
uh who are free to to choose and to
think
and to participate in the health care
system uh i think uh can make those
decisions without
government telling them how to how they
must decide
does that answer your question
well you're saying that at the authority
rights entirely with the insurers is
that the answer
well this bill primarily tells gets the
government away from telling
insurers what they must do so the effect
of this bill would it would be to let
insurers decide what they they think
they should do
so
so like any good argument i think uh
this bill will let insurers do what they
want to do
i would guess
the senate should continue
under any new rules and regulations
state insurance departments adopt is
i i didn't
follow your question i'm sorry mr chair
i'm asking you said this bill would let
insurance companies do what they want
i would suggest that would only be under
the control of the state insurance
departments correct
yes sir i i
assume that was is understood yes we
have okay
we have insurance we have somebody from
insurance in the batting order here my
second question is
um as part-time ceo of a medical
many of the
[Music]
telemedicine
encounters many of the telephone only
encounters
occur
from
our physical facility
which we still have to pay heat light
rent on still have to have a supportive
staff so the idea that telemedicine
might give insurance companies the
wicked thought of reimbursing at a lower
rate than an in par in
house in person visit uh makes me as
frightened as the several thousand
people who emailed us would you comment
on that please i i
i would say that you're
i would generalize your point to be
the cost structures of inpatient care or
in-person care and telemedicine those
cost structures are fundamentally
different
yeah there are some overlaps but the
cost structures are fundamentally
different it's because those cost
structures are different that i think
the pricing mechanism ought to also be
adaptable to accommodate
the relevant cost structures so so i
again i don't presume the insurance
companies to be
um
an adversarial part of our health care
system
prior to 2018 they were reimbursing for
telemedicine at a much better rate and
much more coverage than the state
government was
so i i think we should have a little bit
more faith that that uh
clinical re-engineering is essential
the technology gives us new tools that
we don't have there will be newer tools
and more re-engineering that can take
place in the future i think we need an
adaptable flexible system i believe this
bill does happen all right one more for
me before i uh turn it over to others as
a person who is a strong believer in
having a great deal of faith i also know
that i have to hire a person on my staff
because it is adversarial and sometimes
we have to fight for what is right and
we tie up and waste a lot of money going
into a battle that shouldn't be fought
because it is adversarial that is not a
question and i am now going to call on
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
representative uh
edward for taking my question
um in in the uh amendment um as uh
representative knurk has identified
there's the phrase
the clinical methodologies uh and
efficacy of research accepted da da da
da
um
there to me there's two parts to that
one
is the the um
uh content of that conversation uh uh
specifically the audio uh and also the
efficacy
um
uh trying to separate these out uh
uh
uh medicare medicaid and oftentimes uh
uh third-party insurances uh do chart
reviews
uh is there any place here
to be sure
that in fact the appropriate kinds of
audio only
interactions are appropriate to have
thank you dr woods representative woods
i am
um
not somebody who spends
my day-to-day
in
uh
in the billing bill review chart review
part of the health care system
i
believe that those systems are in place
where
charts can get reviewed clinical
efficacy of various practices can be
reviewed
and reimbursement decisions can be made
in that way
the
i invented the phrase
in accordance with good clinical
methodologies
supported by clinical fspc research or
accepted clinical practice
to basically get the state of new
hampshire
out of price setting
and to allow
other experts to do use their
regular procedures
for determining what emerging
standards of care should be reimbursable
there
there are new reimbursable decisions
being made every year and so i just
think this would be added to the pile of
decisions that would need to be made
uh if you have a better term either you
or dr uh representative kenner i i'm not
wed to the term i'm was intending to
communicate
that
there are practices that occur
in the insurance industry that should be
thank you uh
yeah
i'm going to suggest that we uh just
take the committee people with hands up
at the present time and then
move on uh i'd like to call on somebody
from the insurance
department who might be able to answer
this better but we have representative
cofault in the queue and then
representative shapiro so representative
cofoult
thank you mr chairman um so
representative edwards um i i think the
the timing of this was a key concern and
i understand that's being addressed by
amendment so
um or that can be addressed by amendment
so i think that's uh that's a a move in
the right direction
um i guess you know on its face i think
a lot of people are reading this and
they're seeing this as a
um sort of a question of of uh paying
paying for someone's time differently if
it's remote versus if it is in person
um you stated that the cost structure is
fundamentally different for telehealth
um i think there there is a you know
over the longer term there may be
telemedicine
um alternatives that do create
efficiencies and have a fundamentally uh
different cost structure but
i think for most people this is seen as
a question of time spent working
remotely versus time spent
in the room physically with a patient so
i guess i'm trying to understand um sort
of
how you see this as
how you see the cost structure as being
fundamentally different
um
because again i think the the main
concern is a lot of people just feeling
like this is
um
really about the time they're spending
with their patients uh
one way versus another way
um the the the telemedicine alternative
being something that has uh is very
important not only during the pandemic
but for some patients who have
difficulty uh getting out and about um
can also be uh convenient to them so so
you can allow can you elaborate on the
some of the sort of the longer term
implications around telemedicine and how
you think the cost structure could
well
let's look at what has happened
into the field of mammography
mammography used to require a
radiologist who would spend a great deal
of time looking for very very small
micro calcifications
that that unless you were really trained
and really experienced would would uh be
very difficult in many cases to see
so one of the things that has happened
because the digitization of mammography
the technology introduction is that we
now have computer-aided diagnosis which
doesn't do the job for the radiologist
but it it uses artificial intelligence
to take a look at those uh the patterns
and to highlight for the radiologists
some areas of concern that can be
checked off almost like a little
checklist
and so the uh
the uh effectiveness of the mammograph
fist
and
the the time involved have changed as a
result of the introduction of technology
at its core it's the same you have a
person reading an image but the
technology has fundamentally changed
how much time gets spent and the the
quality of how it gets spent
so so in the future with telemedicine
we're going to be able to take all of
these biotech feeds that come from our
wearables particularly if we have
chronic conditions and those will be
monitored by an artificial intelligence
system that can determine whether we're
in standard or not and to send us to
inpatient care or in-person care or not
depending on those metrics
the way that person inter engages in the
health care system is going to be
fundamentally different it'll raise
questions of
it when that artificial intelligence
software kicks in and says hey
you need to go see somebody now is that
a clinical visit is that a billable
clinical visit
under under the eo i think you could
argue that it is
but what i but to answer your your
question representative
is that
i think we can see these examples of
where technology insertions
actually does change
uh the quality access and cost
parameters of how health care gets
provided
and our clinical systems will continue
to be re-engineered to take advantage of
it for example nobody did telemedicine
or few people did telemedicine 20 years
ago now we're debating you know how much
we should pay for it in 20 years we're
going to be debating you know something
totally different about technology and
whether or not
it's killing our local communities
because people in montana are
doing telemedicine services for our
patients in laconia
you know so
so
everything's going to shift because of
technology
so
um
i talk a lot i hope i address your
question
um
yes i i'm
i'm not sure if this is a follow-up or
just a con
an observation you know that the
definition under may follow up or
observed go ahead okay thank you mr
chairman um so the observation is that
telemedicine um
many of many of the
many of the sections under the uh under
the original bill
specify
persons uh
licensed by the board shall be permitted
to provide services through the use of
telemedicine so i i
suspect that might preclude some of the
um some of the artificial intelligence
technology you're you're discussing but
um i'll i'll leave it at that
thank you
as a footnote i just emailed you uh
amendment 205h which corrected the
missing 180 days so
i'm sorry for the chaotic nature of the
amendments but you should have one in
your inbox that does what i intended
thank you representative edwards i would
like to call on
uh dj bettencourt and or chris necopolis
from the insurance department if either
or both of those are still
in the meeting could they be brought up
please
good morning mr chairman this is dj
betancourt is my volume okay your volume
is wonderful welcome
very good sir thank you very much
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record my name is
dj bettencourt and i have the pleasure
of serving as the deputy commissioner of
the new hampshire insurance department
i've been on the job for about two weeks
now and i'm getting my feet wet and so
this is my a testimonial debut in this
new role so
take it easy on me if you would sure
yeah right
[Laughter]
uh as has been the long-standing uh
policy of the insurance department i am
here this morning not to take a position
on this particular piece of legislation
but rather to share some thoughts with
you for your consideration
as you know 2020 was a big and
significant year for telemedicine
including legislative changes that
included a number of insurance
requirements associated with
telemedicine coverage and payment
it's important to appreciate that given
how rapidly the landscape has expanded
for telemedicine it is really too early
to fully understand the totality of what
those impacts will be as it pertains to
the health insurance market
as an example telemedicine has obviously
been an important tool during the covet
19 pandemic to minimize as best as
possible of course under the
circumstances
disruption to patient care and has
allowed patients to continue having
access to their health care providers
what is less clear however going forward
is what the continued demand for
telehealth services will be as the
pandemic subsides
for some this new innovation will be
their preferred method of accessing care
but for others they will be eager to
return to the familiarity of a clinical
setting
but the degree to which individuals fall
into one bucket or the other is going to
be important for
everyone to monitor
following these issues closely is going
to be i think an important task for the
commission to study telehealth services
that was created last year
to really
carefully look at
one thing that this committee and others
is going to want to monitor is the
potential for unexpected pressure on
health insurance premiums and there are
some specific questions
i think that are going to be important
to bear in mind
the first is will the most expensive
in-person providers be the ones to
expand their telemedicine services the
most
the second will be
will competition among health care
providers decline because carriers can't
negotiate telemedicine rates separately
from in-person rates
and finally will the preferred
telemedicine providers be out of state
without an in-person equivalent rate
again the answers to those questions i
don't believe can be fully answered
because we lack the benefit of long-term
data trends
and a non-coveted pandemic experience
however the policy choices in reaction
to them are for you the legislature to
decide
coverage for audio only services is a
significant policy development and
monitoring how that plays out i think is
going to be an important course of
action
my final comment here
on behalf of tyler brennan who is par
excellence in the insurance department
when it comes to
uh health insurance is that the
uh provision that um the new provision
that removes some potentially confusing
language as it pertains to in person
is a positive change from an enforcement
perspective
but on that point i also want to be
clear we are only commenting on that to
the extent that the previous language
had raised some questions and confusion
and i appreciate the fact that
representative edwards has
attempted to clarify some of that so my
comment should not be seen as an opinion
on the value or drawbacks of the
reimbursement parity policy decision but
just that
we do appreciate the fact that there was
an attempt to clean up some confusing
language as with that said mr chairman i
will do my absolute best to answer
questions and if i don't have the answer
for you today i will certainly get it
for you in very short short order
well all i can say is i wish i was that
good two weeks into any job i've ever
started thank you so much representative
shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
mr betancourt for taking my question
you said that your department was
neutral on this bill
um
and yet you spoke about the
commission on telemedicine which was um
part of house bill 1623
which was tasked with
um
researching the use of telemedicine and
making recommendations for the future um
i don't want to read too much into what
you said but
do you think it's wise that
changes in the telemedicine
provisions come out of that commission
well thank you representative for the
question i i think the ultimate
determination of who should make the
decisions on policy
uh is one that you and the members of
that commission should decide what i am
very firm on is that it is not the role
of the insurance department our role is
to
enforce the insurance rules and
regulations that are on the books those
rules and regulations come as a result
of the deliberation of the legislature
and other legislative commissions and
committees and boards and
that is what we will always continue to
do
thank you
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
bettencourt for taking my question
is it not
a significant possibility
if we adopt the language in the proposed
amendment
that without the requirement for parity
insurance companies
who have a great deal more bargaining
power than any individual practitioner
will particularly in the area of mental
health practice
sees the opportunity to lower rates
which we already know
are
woefully inadequate
to ensure that
practitioners get even less
reimbursement for their services than
they are now getting
thank you for the question
representative a possibility yes
but what
my testimony i think speaks to is that
the extent to which that
would be the case i think is still
somewhat unknown again because you have
had a very rapid
um
expansion of telehealth in a very short
period of time
you don't quite have the data of those
long-term trends to tell you the degree
thank you
representative
merchant thank you mr chairman
uh director bettencourt
when i look at the healthcare market
today it's relatively fragmented in the
payer
um so
help me understand what part of the
healthcare market this is actually
applying to you know look at medicare
medicaid under arista you got
self-funded plans you've got commercial
plans so what part of this market are we
actually talking about how large is it
compared to the overall market
well thank you for the question
representative i think certainly you're
looking at the the individual market
uh certain you're certainly you're
looking potentially at the large and
small group markets
if i may mr chairman you may
so basically the market that's left that
this applies to is the most vulnerable
market we have in the marketplace
because to representative weber's point
of view these are people that don't have
the bargaining power to actually stand
up to the insurance industry to
negotiate on their own so my concern is
that we're basically leaving these
people here without some sort of defense
upon how they can receive the care in
an appropriate manner but also
economically provide
some sort of reimbursement to the
appreciate the concern representative
and again how you'd like to proceed in
addressing that issue is entirely in the
purview of this committee in the
legislature
thank you sir representative betancourt
uh one of the options as you know that
we have
um is to retain a bill and work on it
over the summer
and it sounds to me like you're looking
for a
more longitudinal
uh set of data let's go out three or
four months more and see what we've got
not asking you to make a recommendation
but just your own
common sense uh now two weeks on the job
would waiting longer to look at
additional data seem to run parallel
with what you've been telling us
thank you mr chairman um my
long-standing philosophy has always been
that more information and more data
generally gets you to a better end
result
but whether or not you'd like to go that
direction of course is entirely up to
you thank you very much and um may you
be blessed as you head into your third
week of employment
thank you mr chairman
representative
william marsh
hello can people hear me
we can
very good i'm trying to participate
myself on this my internet has gone down
and uh thank you mr chairman for taking
my question and uh thank you dj for
participating with our hearing today
it's a pleasure to meet with you under
other circumstances um my question has
to do with the the federal 1135 waiver
which temporarily allows audio only
telehealth during the coveted 1910
endemic and as we all sincerely hope
someday the covet 19 pandemic is going
to come to an end
is it going to create a problem that we
have actually put audio only telehealth
into statute here
if it is no longer allowed under federal
i'm sorry representative marsh i missed
the question
right
under federal law we are allowed to do
audio only telehealth because of an 1135
waiver that was issued pursuant to 42
usc uh 320b 5b
because previously that was not allowed
to be reimbursed by the center for
medicaid and medicare services
are we going to have a problem that we
have put audio only services into new
hampshire statute as being reimbursable
if it ceases to be allowed under federal
law by this temporary waiver that was
only put in place for the coveted 19
pandemic uh thank you representative for
repeating your question uh i i don't
know for certain that of course is is
potentially a problem uh but that's
something that i'm going to have to take
back to my department uh and
get some further information for you at
a later time
uh thank you and mr chairman may have a
follow-up you may
yes and uh would you would you agree
that the research for that might take
some time which of course is a good
reason for us to retain this bill so
that we can work on whatever issues you
raise
and have a vehicle to deal with them
thank you representative
some of you are trying to drag me into
the the opinion department here as to uh
what you should do with this bill and
i'm not gonna do it
[Laughter]
not that kind of guy
no but but what i what i pledge to do is
to get as much information for this
committee as quickly as i can uh that
that's my commitment
i i i thank you it was a rhetorical
question
[Laughter]
have you ever thought uh mr uh
bettencourt of a career in
politics i i tried it uh once or twice
thank you representative weber do you
my apologies no that was just
inattention on my part that is fine
um
well seeing that there's no more
questions from
the uh committee for mr bettencourt
we do have a few people
from the public who would wish to speak
and
just a reminder
that the bill
so many people reacted to
up until last night
there is now a significant amendment in
place so please testify
to that
and not to what you may have read last
night
and with that i
i see on my screen
a
representative melbourne is it morin or
moran
in either case uh you're invited to
speak
hi thank you mr chairman it's uh
representative melbourne moran i'm also
a licensed independent clinical social
worker
um i represent um national ward 7
hillsboro district 34.
um i'm really speaking to you today i'm
a small business owner i own a
psychotherapy practice here in nashua i
also have another site in massachusetts
all right i briefly got the overview of
the amendments and even as the amendment
is written i believe that this is a
small business crusher we cannot compete
uh with our larger
hospital systems and contracting and
negotiations uh and i understand that we
don't want to do price fixing as
government
but in this case you know we um
here especially for me in my practice
uh we intend as a for-profit business to
compete with the larger mental health
centers and other larger uh facilities
in this state and if that's undercut
here by the state by passing such
legislation we won't be able to compete
and
grow and expand
you know we're not a group of
practitioners who are just academic and
part-time take on a client or two and
make ourselves feel good
we're actually trying to do uh the best
we can for our community uh by treating
and using uh as many resources as we can
to reach as many people as we can for
example with telehealth expansion i've
had to buy an emr that supports hipaa
compliant telehealth services but with
that i'm able to see clients that are in
the lakes region while i'm in my office
in nashua uh we've been able to expand
access to rural
folks in our state uh that may have not
been able to access that from their
local mental health centers who have
tremendous wait list uh we also take
amerihealth and new hampshire healthy
families uh uh already compared to our
uh the private insurance companies that
we um contract with uh who are not only
just reimbursing at a full rate they are
also um
paying for the co-pays of um the private
practitioner private clients that come
through um if we uh pass a bill uh that
is being proposed even as amended uh i
for sure see um medicaid uh contractors
reducing our telehealth uh benefit uh
reimbursement rate
uh with that said uh i i do think again
uh we have to con consider the
self-employed and the small businesses
here that don't have such great
bargaining uh power as the larger
hospitals uh thank you for your time mr
chairman and committee members would you
take questions representative
that's great because my daughter wants
her computer back
well
thank your daughter for that we'll move
on thank you representative thank you
hi
this is dr kristin johnson
uh thanks so much for allowing me to
participate today and good morning from
snowy southern new hampshire
my name is dr kristen johnson i'm
speaking as a resident of new fields and
as a practicing board certified
pediatrician from exeter i've spoken to
this committee in the past and see some
familiar faces
on specifically about telemedicine most
recently
in the last year or two on expanding the
definition of originating sites to
include schools
over the past year
the kobit 19 pandemic has certainly
pushed telemedicine as we've heard into
the mainstream as healthcare was forced
to use creativity to balance the
healthcare needs of our community with
the stressors of reducing close contact
as a transmission risk factor for some
families with high risk health
conditions this risk reduction has
continued in dramatic fashion
in addition we've seen changes to the
daily routines
for adults and children students are
doing uh in person hybrid and remote
learning and we just heard from our
representative that his daughter's
stealing his computer back uh parents
are working remotely
as all of you are uh here today uh but
also many are returning to their
in-person jobs this uh balance has been
very difficult for families including
mine
and adding in healthcare has been a real
challenge this is true for both routine
well and chronic care as well as more
urgent and emerging issues
in our practice in pediatrics in exeter
with core we've worked to find a balance
of keeping our patients in quarantine
yet not having them miss out on their
medical care telemedicine has been a
critical part of this we've had students
learning from home and parents back at
work in person a three-way telemedicine
visit has provided access to care for
that student
and the parents can participate from
work as well and really allowing
everybody in that family to uh
participate in that healthcare
children with potentially uh having
coveted symptoms can be seen from home
if they're otherwise feeling okay
and we're offering testing without them
even having to leave their car that
limits the contact with others in our
office
as well as adding convenience for our
patients and parents maintaining a
healthy staff as i'm sure you guys are
all very aware has been one of the
challenges in keeping our healthcare
system uh open and this format has
really helped to stabilize the health of
our workforce
examples of these visits from my
practice just yesterday included a
family reviewing their child's anxiety
and adhd medication management from home
since there's an infant in their family
with congenital heart disease and
they're trying to limit their exposures
a teen with depression who is able to
talk to me from their bedroom
in a comfortable setting talking about
some pretty difficult topics for them
uh and a child who met with me from home
while the parent was at work um the
video was used for the child mom
couldn't get her video to work it was
only available by audio and i realized
we've taken some of that component out
but again just as an example uh a few
things that have required uh
telemedicine just the last 24 hours for
me
uh this pandemic has brought many awful
things but what we have learned about
telemedicine is one of the bright spots
uh in our learning today in the
snowstorm we'll we'll have less
disruption to the care of our patients
as we can keep them off our slippery
roads
yet allow them to keep their planned
care well telemedicine as we've heard is
certainly not appropriate for all
situations it has allowed us to be more
agile during this pandemic and to
extrapolate that to other situations
snowstorms kids and parents in separate
locations poor access to transportation
etc
payment for telemedicine has been an
ongoing challenge until this pandemic
accelerated the payment equity in the
setting of the state emergency and the
advantage of access to telemedicine are
clear in the correct setting and with
equal payment being critical to
supporting ongoing access i oppose house
bill 602 changing the payments for these
visits they should continue to follow
the now standard billing for medic for
medical care
uh we haven't spoken much to it but the
new 2021 billing structure
has really changed
our day-to-day billing and really
focuses on the time spent with patients
on their coordinated care on the time
for documentation
and the other work that we do to care
for our patients in this format really
supports the equal payment for time with
less focus on the components of physical
exam and physical presence certainly
supporting the care is care and that the
location of our patient and our provider
are not as critical in our new
understanding of our federal health care
payment system
previous legislation
passed by
you guys here in new hampshire
requiring medicaid and medicare to pay
for
telemedicine
it wasn't paid for at all before this
we never were reimbursed
and
typically what we see is that our
private insurances follow the lead of
the state medicaid and medicare
populations and what you choose to do to
support that
my opposition of this bill um is both in
its initial and modified form
so that we can maintain uh moving
forward with adequate payment for the
advantageous progress that we're making
uh regardless of our location of
services uh thank you for your time and
i'll submit a formal copy of that by
email and i'm happy to answer questions
if i could be helpful
thank you dr johnson the chair now
good morning mr chairman it's good to
see you all i know you've had a long
morning already and uh
i
am proud that i worked with senator
bradley
representative marsh
the legislation for house bill 1623 in
the last session
which established the
telehealth
parity
provided for
services to be provided by multiple
licensed practitioners in the state of
the parties who agreed to that
legislation
were
the department of hhs and the medicaid
services the department of insurance
health insurance plan providers the
hospital association behavioral health
association the medical society
uh
so you can you can see we uh we not only
had uh
bipartisan support we had uh
broad support from uh state agencies
uh the insurance markets and providers
uh
i want to say i've worked with
representative edwards on a number of
bills uh uh we've had uh good
uh colleague
relationships uh and
[Music]
unfortunately when it comes to this bill
uh i'm speaking today in opposition to
this bill
uh look forward to working with
representative edwards in the future on
things in which we have mutual interest
but on this
i think this is a very poorly timed bill
one of the things that was created in
the
house bill 1623 passage last year was
the creation of a commission to study
telehealth services
i serve on that as the chairperson
and
serving on that commission
14-member commission with me
are
representative dr woods
and representative dr marsh
they both have a great deal to
contribute
along with the other
members of the commission who represent
all the groups that i said we had come
together you heard from dj betancourt
the department of insurance has been
engaged
through tyler brennan
who's working
with the study committee
um
we were scratching the surface let me
let me also add that the study
commission
in its enabling
legislation has two reporting dates
the first is
for
december 1st of 2022
the second is
december 1st of 2024
at which time the commission would
sunset
uh
the idea that the parties who came
together to to
was that we need to get past this
pandemic and see what the adoption rate
uh uh post
pandemic actually is for the uses of
telemedicine telehealth
uh and uh
and and establish some baseline
data uh we started to scratch the
surface on data
uh
it's uh
the
uh
medicaid
allows us to look at private insurers
what we can observe is that the
information lags uh in order to to get
good
uh breakdowns on the uses and
reimbursements by category of use
uh takes uh as much as six months to
have that
be in a reportable format the point
being
our december 22nd report is probably
going to reflect on usage up until
the summer
of
which isn't a whole lot
long way off uh hopefully we have a
year's worth of non-covet-related
experience
that we can compare to the pandemic
crisis use
uh
but that that we'll see that down the
road
um
we know that the adoption rates in
health care delivery it's slow i come
they compete neck and neck for
change in their their practices
parity is an important part to encourage
this market to evolve uh the study
commission's role
uh is to look at that to solicit
information from health care providers
on their use
from commercial payers from medicaid
uh and uh from uh users patient uh uh
data to to see how well it's worked for
patients
uh and to determine if there are
uh cost structures that perhaps are
different for
types of services
that might be offered under telehealth
but we don't have that evidence today
and i guess if there's any overused term
in today's pandemic healthcare
environment it is let's do this on an
evidence-based uh
manner and uh
and let that evolve and and please use
the study commission uh as a means of
reporting as it is intended to the
this committee and in the senate
health and human services committee
to the governor and uh
let us use this commission
as it was written
to to be a
a means for consolidating evidence-based
practice
and cost evidence
to bring forward to the legislature in
an appropriate time when we've got
sufficient information to do so
thank you senator khan i was really
hoping you would sign in on this because
of your work on that commission i just
thought i i thought i had okay well i'm
glad you did i didn't see it until about
10 minutes ago
but thank you and i do have one question
for you uh if we were to retain the bill
we would be working on it in september
and october
um
if we itled the bill something would
come back
uh put into the hopper we'd look at it
next january or february in your
personal opinion in terms of the lag of
knowing the data
would our working on it in september
october be sufficiently far out
for us to come up with some really good
conclusions or would those good
conclusions better wait a year
i think your latter point mr chairman is
uh more accurate i think
uh
you'll still be looking at
pandemic uh
months
uh
data
you won't be able to to bring the data
current to
uh your considerations in the fall
thank you and with that i am going to
recess the hearing on this and i will be
taking it up sometime as late as i
possibly can
and therefore anyone who then wishes to
call to us
please read amendments that have come
forward and may come forward in the
future
thank you so much this
particular hearing on
house bill 602 now is
recessed and i will um
give us five minutes
how you doing big guy
you can mute
okay
um you're still not muted jeff save your
work jeff are you there
yeah we need to save your work i'm going
to make a motion for retention
muted ken you did look muted and then
you touched it and it
unmuted you
please
hello this is representative marsh can
anybody confirm that we're still
connected i'm worried that i lost my
cell phone and that's introduce the next
bill i can hear you i can hear you i can
hear you
thank you guys
this is stressing me out that i lost my
internet in the middle of the hearing
yeah
better internet up north it's another
argument for audio only i have a bit i
have a bill in about that
yeah
i'm in support of that
we need audio only telehealth because of
situations like this
you got it and can't discuss that out
you can't discuss the bill
but uh yeah
bill is due to the wind did that take
you down
i don't know i would have to plow out my
driveway and then drive down the road
and see but yeah hosted telephone and
the internet i know it's the cable and
fortunately the electricity hasn't gone
out so
but this does seem to happen on a
the it is really heavy on the wires and
the trees here in salem
you're somewhat north of my district
representative marsh if i remember i
represent metro boston
new hampshire is north of your district
all right where is my gavel here it is
aha okay
i am
we're opening uh house hearing on house
bill 163 relative to cannabis use during
pregnancy
and
we are going to give him although he's
using the phone
the same courtesy
as if it was tele testifying or in
person it will be the same courtesy
representative marsh
well
thank you mr chairman and and thank you
this is a novel concept introducing a
bill over telephone but uh for the
record i'm representative william marsha
you all know me on the committee i
represent carroll county eight seven
towns in southern carroll county and i'm
pleased today to introduce to you house
bill 163 relative to cannabis use during
pregnancy
this bill was inspired by an article
published in jama june 18 2019 entitled
association between self-reported
prenatal cannabis use and maternal
perinatal and neonatal outcomes
briefly a cohort study of over 660 000
pregnancies in ontario canada found the
rate of preterm birth among reported
cannabis users was 12 percent versus 6
percent and non-users a statistically
significant difference clearly that's
neither good for the babies nor the
health insurers
this confirmed a previously reported
study from colorado in the journal
pediatrics in 2018.
meanwhile a june 2018 study in
obstetrics gynecology reported that a
survey of 400 cannabis dispensaries in
colorado found 69 percent of them
recommending cannabis for first
trimester morning sickness
my survey of available medical
literature about this was made much
simpler by our surgeon general jerome
adams who issued an advisory on
marijuana in the developing brain in
august 29
2019.
in addition to the concern about
pre-term births dr adams is rightly
concerned about subsequent learning
disabilities
for details interested committee members
www.hhs.gov and look at the report
if and when i get my computer back i'll
be glad to email you a link to the
report
after i filed this bill last year abby
rogers from dhhs contacted me and asked
me to expand its scope slightly to
include cannabis use while lactating and
the risk of accidental poisoning and i
redrafted the bill with their language i
similarly did so this year after filing
the bill
there are two difference between this
bill and last year's bill
house bill 1591 last year passed this
committee 18 to nothing and was adopted
on consent but died a covet death in the
senate
we added language about cannabis use
during adolescence to reflect the
surgeon general's concern
and we asked the department to document
through rules that counseling had
happened that could be as simple as a
check box on the certification form
the entire effect of this bill is to
acquire conspicuous warnings be posted
and information be made available
mirroring that that's currently being
made available in colorado work is
already being done on educational
materials which i believe representative
canark intends to share i thank you and
representative acton
all right uh thank you mr chair and uh
good morning representative marsh thank
you for taking my question um this is
obviously a no-brainer
but the question i have is
are we getting into the situation where
we're going to just be adding
bits of of health information here and
there where we should maybe take a step
back and create a process of
communicating from
the um hhs to the individual patients
now
they they do send out letters and so
forth but there's no they don't have
email lists and so forth
that's also seen um
as as security
issues of of not wanting to be exposed
as taking part in the program but i just
wonder if we are going to keep
encountering these um these medical
bulletins and so putting them in into
the law one by one
seems
you know self-defeating where we could
create a system where
you know that handles
a little bit differently
thank you uh
thank you representative i'm i'm glad
for your question um
i i would like things like this to
happen automatically but as we know
things happen when the squeak when the
wheel squeaks and we were told last year
that the department had been meaning to
get around to doing this for about five
years and hadn't quite done it
i think you and i both recognize that at
some point in time it is highly likely
that our state will join the states
around us and make uh cannabis more
widely available to the public and i
will admit that one of my intentions
here was to have the department develop
materials so that when that day comes
they could more widely distribute their
materials but that would be a different
bill for a different day
this bill is just to require the
materials to be developed for the
dispensaries
representative gay
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
how many ways do we have to notify the
public
um
i mean
it is a no-brainer but it's a no-brainer
to us
and unfortunately in our culture there
are lots of people who just don't want
to think there's anything negative about
using cannabis
so we've already discussed a bill
about
about using cannabis for medical
purposes
which i'm guessing
doesn't apply to being pregnant
so
you know this to me seems like a really
basic
basic way to say that it's extremely
dangerous and if we're going to talk
about marijuana at all
this ought to be part of it
uh and it is you know in my book it is
affected tremendously by
uh
by the law
so
how many other ways can we tell people
this just seems like one really critical
way
thank you representative for your
question i do believe that the
department intends to testify on this
bill they did on our bill last year
and i believe that they can answer that
question far better than i can so i will
let them do so
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman and also thank you
representative for taking my question
i commend this bill i think it's a step
in the right direction um i would
actually go a step farther if we could
when i look at other
things available to us in the
marketplace
to protect the unborn
um we put labels on nicotine we put
labels on to alcohol particularly
alcohol
i think this is a step as far as
informing the person in the dispensary
was there any thought put into adding a
label onto the product itself once it
leaves the dispensary versus just being
inside of the dispensaries
uh
thank you representative for your
question i think the issue of labeling
of product is an important question and
in fact i happen to know that there's a
bill before the commerce committee to
that effect uh but that's not the bill
that we're discussing here today and it
never crossed my mind to put labels uh
on it when i wrote this bill but i agree
with you that it's a very reasonable
idea and i would suggest you address
your comments to the commerce committee
representative jerry kanerk
is a co-sponsor and has done a lot of
work on this subject and i would like to
invite him to testify on this bill
thank you mr chair everybody hear me
okay yep
okay um yes for the record i'm
representative jerry connerk and
representing carol iii but i also serve
as the chair of the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board
this is the board that is tasked with
looking over the medical issues involved
in the therapeutic cannabis program we
heard about the other board that we've
already voted to get rid of and because
that had to do with just kind of the
function and getting it up and running
this is an ongoing board to look at
medical questions
so we have actually been dealing with
this for over a year now
first i have to point out that one
important thing is that the surgeon
general's report
had to do with cannabis in general
not just therapeutic cannabis he was
talking about recreational and
therapeutic and the great majority of
users who are pregnant or adolescents
are actually recreational users
the data regarding cannabis risk
that we have so far to use to make
decisions actually comes from the
recreational users as the therapeutic
cannabis literature is just emerging the
risks in therapeutic use may be
different than in recreational use due
to the different patterns and the
different dosage having said that
we still share the concerns
so it's important to understand that the
goal of using cannabis in the
therapeutic setting is different from
the goal in recreational use
it's not used to get high but instead to
treat a condition the doses of
therapeutic cannabis are titrated using
rubric that we call
low and slow you start with a low dose
and you slowly build to achieve the
therapeutic effect while minimizing the
side effect of euphoria
it is important to understand that the
peak ages for certified patients in the
tcmob sorry the therapeutic cannabis
program in new hampshire is in the 50s
and the 60s that's the age group
for a 2021 senate bill we just
interrogated the database regarding the
number of certified patients less than
age 21.
25 is in this bill but 21 was the other
that's
how we interrogate it
out of
688 total qualifying patients in the
therapeutic cannabis program in new
hampshire there are only 10 minors under
age 18
and 66 patients between 18 and 20. so it
is actually also a fairly small group
that doesn't take away the importance
the tcmv tcmob has not had the chance to
review this particular view it's on our
agenda for tomorrow
we did review the 2020 version of the
bill hb 1591 which addressed pregnancy
and lactation
but did not include this section in
adolescence and we voted to support the
bill 9-1 with an initial recommendation
to add a requirement for counseling by
both the atc and the certifying provider
for all women of child varying age about
the risk of cannabis during pregnancy
and lactation
the next month though we revisited our
thoughts on this and we then expressed
concerns with each other about the at
staff
atc staff that's remember atc's are the
dispensaries about the staff
qualifications to provide such
counseling and also difficulties with
gender determination and profiling of
women of child-bearing age
we realized that asking the atc to
provide the counseling about
risk of cannabis in women in
childbearing age would actually hold
therapeutic cannabis perhaps to a higher
standard than we do with other drugs in
the pharmacy so we felt that actually we
would not support
the counseling and the atc but we felt
the counseling did belong in the
certifying provider's office
so one of the main goals for the for the
board in 2020 was to develop educational
materials we have already developed
educational sheets regarding the risks
of cannabis use during pregnancy and
lactation both for providers
and for patients and we're ready to
proceed with the implementation of these
educational initiatives
now i sent to you when i sent this
testimony to you a couple of days ago i
included those information sheets again
we've approved the content that's the
kind of content we expect would be used
in some of the informational and
educational work we work on
representative martial included a
requirement for counseling in the new
bill placing the burden of counseling on
the certifying provider which is where
we feel it should be
we have not reviewed this particular
language but given that we've already
agreed with the counseling being done by
the certifying provider i'm pretty sure
they'll be happy with this
the new bill also has a requirement for
warnings of the risk of cannabis in
adolescence
though we have not had a chance to
discuss that particular requirement in
the context of the language of this bill
we have discussed and recognized the
risks of cannabis use in adolescence and
we have already developed educational
slides for providers regarding these
risks
and that educational slide deck was also
attached to the email i sent you a
couple of days ago
you also may note uh late last night i
sent an email that had um
pdfs of some of these then of the more
detailed educational decks
and those included some posters and
other types of educational materials
used in some other states that gives you
an idea what representative mark should
be talking about with this bill that
he's discussing
so i would expect that tcmob will
probably support this new section of the
bill
and will develop educational materials
for the risks of cannabis use and
adolescence
now a couple of things that i did have
some questions about
uh the reconstant requirement on page
two line seven
probably needs to be amended so on the
bill
page two line seven because it talks
about counseling for women of child
bearing age in adolescents 25 years or
less
we would need to say counseling for
patients less than age 18 needs to
include the parent or the guardian
just for the usual issues we do in
medical care the
patient should be counseled but in this
case probably a parent and guardian as
well
i also though question whether the
specific risks should be prescribed in
statute this is done if we look at page
lines 13 to 14
and lines 22 to 25
that identifies which risks need to be
enumerated
but we do know that medical knowledge
evolves over time
perhaps the decision of the risks to be
included should be made by the tcmob
i would say though that we are
our lists are almost identical so we
have no difficulty with that sorry i
cannot say we here we have now looked at
the new language i do not and i do not
expect that board would have difficulty
with the language of the risks that are
used but the question is do we want it
scalable for the future by keeping out
some of those
uh details that might change over
time with changing medical knowledge
regarding representative gay's question
we are working to disseminate this
information to providers and to the
patients for the patients a handout
also
a poster we would agree with that
concept that's in this bill
and also again because of the counseling
required um we would be very happy if
the pro if the certifying provider
uh did also review these issues so i am
quite sure that we will agree with this
bill since we agreed with last year's
nine to one but we have not had a time
to go over the exact language that's
tomorrow thank you
thank you representative canuck and
before i recognize anyone to ask you
questions i see that representative
casey conley is on the call and
representative conley it is my intent to
move right into your bill after this one
and i hope it won't be very long so
hang in there brother
the chair recognizes representative
woods
uh thank you mr chair and uh
thank you representative mark for taking
my question
i remember those papers and read them
when they came out but i don't recall
the content the cbd versus thc
the reason i ask we know that
the cbd part uh can be quite useful
medically uh i.e in the um
newborn and the very young with seizure
disorders
um has that was that parsed out and i
think it's probably important to know
because we've uh have bills and we have
actually standalone
companies now
uh selling just cbds and that would be
helpful to be able to provide that
information
do were those uh studies
uh
to whom are you addressing your question
um
to uh representative marsh or uh
knurk
i just don't recall the paper
uh they might and i think it's important
to make that we can differentiate
do you ever tell me to take that
representative marsh
uh well i would just say to the best of
my recollection it wasn't addressed but
since i can't look up the paper because
my computer's down
i can't really answer it well
point of order mr chairman i think it
would be simpler for all of us trying to
follow along at home
if only the person who is currently
testifying is asked questions and we
don't switch between the person who's
currently on
in the batter's box
um thank you
go further afield
thank you and that would be
representative canark
okay well i'd i'd be glad to i'd be glad
to speak to that
are you can you hear me i'm not
highlighted there we are okay now i am
um basically again as i said earlier
most of the data we have regarding
therapeutic cannabis sorry regarding
cannabis risks comes from the
uh
from the recreational field and the
whole point with recreational is most
the time it's really not regulated most
the time we don't really know and most
the studies that we've looked at don't
separate those out we are just finally
getting some studies relating to just
cbd you are correct cbd has very
distinct uses and is actually approved
as epidiolex for seizure disorders
but we still do not have enough data to
let us know whether or not
one
strain is released that much safer than
the other strain so it's still the data
is in its infancy but most of these have
to do with recreational use and as a
result it's usually the standard which
any other questions for representative
canarch
seeing none the chair recognizes michael
uh hello this is michael holt can you
hear me we can
great thank you very much
my name is michael holt i'm representing
the department of health and human
services i am i am the administrator of
the department's therapeutic cannabis
program
was not taking a position on this bill
and i would offer that uh representative
knurk stole much of my uh testimonial
thunder um his points were exactly going
to be my point so i won't reiterate uh
except um
too much except to say that
much of what this bill is mandating is
already being done either required by
statute
administrative rule or practice
some of the differences are this
information needs to be provided in
poster format
um
the uh and the other main point that i
would make is that um
i share the department shares the
concern of codifying
um
these health risks in statute um
cannabis science is evolving we don't
want to lock ourselves in and that the
tcmob the therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board
will be taking a review of this bill up
at tomorrow's uh tomorrow's meeting um
the department would like to see these
um
these
this list of health
adolescents
either be vetted by the board first or
removed from
shoot
entirely and let the board direct us and
the atcs on what information should be
provided
to
patients um
via providers and the alternative
treatment centers
um
so uh that's uh i'll close just by
highlighting the the numbers again um
total patience um 10 688 uh we've got 10
miners on the program uh we have
310 adolescents uh so age 18 to 25
um and uh so the scope of this uh
population is relatively small um women
of reproductive age is estimated to be
about um under 1500 patients um enrolled
in the program
um so i'm happy to answer any questions
from from members
representative knight did most of the
lifting on this one
any questions for mr holt
representative acton
all right
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
holster taking my question i i was
wondering can you give me a ballpark
figure of how many
uh medical
providers there are that have
taken part or recommended uh cannabis to
their patients uh that's that's one part
of the equation i know how many people
we got how many doctors we have out
there taking part
uh we collect this data um
we have about 1200
providers
who have certified at least one patient
and that's the current number
that's not the number of total providers
who
may have certified one patient a number
of years ago but no longer have a
current patient so that's about 1200
providers um about uh
memory says uh close to 200 of those
are upstate providers so about a
thousand in-state providers and about
200 out-of-state providers those
provider types are physicians
aprns
and as of a couple years ago physician
assistants
those are the provider types who can
all right thank you very much that's
impressive numbers
thank you
uh the only other hand up okay he's put
his phone down representative snow
please unmute and ask your question of
chris
hello representative uh mr hall i have
two questions thank you for taking my
question and thank you mr chairman i
have two questions you said that the
information can only be presented in a
poster form
in the end of the bill it says brochures
is that preclude producing a brochure
my testimony was that
much of this information that is
required by this bill is already being
provided by the atc's uh in other
formats this bill would require
specifically a warning poster to be
posted in the dispensary on these two
issues that was the testimony that i
provided okay but that same information
could be produced in a brochure that
could be distributed elsewhere is that
not correct are correct
we uh we currently uh do have a
brochure if you will a double-sided
color copy um that has information about
the program that includes info warnings
about use during pregnancy and while
breastfeeding um and also information
about safe storage disposal and
accidental poisoning this information is
already in brochure form um we do not
have require um
uh big posters to be posted in uh in the
dispensaries at the time that's going to
be a cost for the department to develop
and print um of course um
it's uh it's not uh it's an issue that
we'll talk about in the in the
tcmob meeting tomorrow um but again uh
the the information on adolescents is
not being currently provided um in any
format um so that is a that's a good
addition to this uh to be able to focus
um education efforts on that population
thank you very much mr holt seeing no
further hands raise the chair calls kate
oh he did it
good man members of the committee my
name is kate frye from new futures uh
it's nice to see you all virtually um as
you know we're a non-partisan nonprofit
organization that educates and advocates
to improve the health and wellness of
new hampshire residents
um
and we are here in support of house bill
16163 relative to cannabis use during
pregnancy as representative marsh had
stated there was a jama article that
showed the proportion of u.s women using
um cannabis during pregnancy more than
double between 2002 and 2017
and we all know use during pregnancy can
be harmful um to a baby's health and
include many serious problems
um
we support hb 1633 because it would
require the atcs to pry to provide
information regarding the risk of
cannabis use so i will agree with
representative marsh that this has been
about a five year discussion um new
futures along with prevention partners
created very easy to use educational
documents for the therapeutic cannabis
program and for the atc's back in 2016.
i think those are still the forms that
repre uh might mr holt refer to
um these documents highlight tips for
safe and responsible use child safety
and preventing youth use
and it was a collaborative effort with
the atcs and dhhs and prevention experts
however it's always been unclear whether
they are actually being used
by the atcs and kind of after four or
five years of these discussions
we are advocating we do think it makes
sense to mandate these efforts um and we
would also recommend that these
documents are mailed to clients when
they receive their therapeutic cannabis
id card it'd be a relatively easy thing
to do um i'm not this could be done
already i haven't had a discussion with
the department in quite some time about
this but they're um it's just an eight
by eleven um piece of paper that could
easily be included by
uh with the um cannabis identification
card um as far as the cost goes my
understanding is the governor's
commission on substance misuse um
actually
um set aside ten thousand dollars to
cover the costs for this for the
division of public health services
because um it was being said over and
over again that the therapeutic cannabis
program couldn't cover the cost so i'm
not sure why um this would be an
additional cost to the um
public health
um a couple of things i just wanted to
state too is um again i'm split my
testimony specific to the part of the
bill is cannabis use during pregnancy um
i absolutely agreed with representative
gay that um it's a no-brainer but it
actually makes sense with prevention
efforts sometimes you have to say the
same message over and over again for
folks to hear it so i think it makes
even more sense that
these this information is right in the
fingertips of folks when they receive
the id or when they go into the atc
um
and again we wouldn't advocate that you
have to have a big shiny poster again we
think you could easily put this
information um in the card and have
these available at the atcs and again
because we don't not everybody can walk
into an actual alternative treatment
center you have to have a card it is
unclear whether or not they are
um so it i think um mandating it does
make sense
um i will just touch on i wasn't going
to speak to the part of the bill uh
regarding adolescence use because
honestly i just realized it was in the
bill but one thing i would mention is i
think you do need to be as proactive as
possible i definitely agree that you
should defer this to the
um
clinical oversight board of which
representative connect does a good job
but i think we should look at what other
states are seeing too
once they have moved to recreational um
uh use i was actually on a call from
someone from colorado where right now
who we all know had therapeutic cannabis
for some years and then moved to
recreational they're seeing a huge jump
in the number of um 18 to 20 year olds
who have actually left just recreational
use and have gone to the medical side of
things
mostly under the condition of um pain
and those numbers jump from like 300 in
the age group of zero to 17 to 3 000 in
the group of 18 to 21 and they moved to
this category because there are no taxes
and because the
they can get higher percentage thc
uh
products so i just think we need to be
proactive if indeed we move in this
direction let's learn from other states
who are seeing this um even though you
know as representative uh connect said
the cannabis um cbd is one thing thc is
another thing um and the two different
programs are separate but these other
states are seeing people actually leave
kind of the recreational side and move
back to medical for um reasons that are
beneficiary to them as far as um they
don't have to pay taxes so i just wanted
to bring that to your attention um
and
i think that covers it thank you miss
fry will you take questions absolutely
any questions for
ms
fry
thank you mr chairman i unfortunately
got a phone call right when i was there
and i want to do a follow-up to my last
question
which is if this bill about
medical cannabis users to grow cannabis
themselves
they would not be going to the
dispensaries is there any way we can get
information to them with the same
warning about this that that they would
get if they walked into the uh
dispensary and the second thing is
that i wondered about is uh
is it's probably two mammoths a job to
have anybody really undertake but it
does seem to me that family
practitioners and obstetricians should
really have this information available
to them so i just wondered if mr uh halt
could answer those questions for me
mr halt has left the meeting this
question
is only addressed to kate frye
okay
and she can take the question or not if
she wishes
i will attempt to do my best i think
your first question is if um a home grow
bill were to pass and i'm only speaking
specifically to um
this bill that is really pertinent to
just the alternative treatment centers
who um uh
are under the therapeutic cannabis law
um certainly if home grow passes that's
something that should be considered but
obviously that would be much harder to i
think regulate whereas the atc's it's a
it's um a lot easier so
i think it's just projection to look at
this point whether or not that makes
sense and so i'm just speaking to the
part of the bill today that addresses
the atcs um regarding your question on
um obgyn i think that's a great point i
mean please keep in mind that they don't
um prescribe they what they do is
certify
what providers do is certify
i have had
numerous amount of conversations with ob
gyn who are just stunned you know how
many have um
uh asked them about the use of cannabis
during pregnancy and they try to provide
as much cost and much information as
possible around the risks and that there
are other options for medication for
things like um
morning sickness so uh you know i think
they have uh
they have a genuine concern about how
they get this question over and over and
over again and so that's enough to for
me to think that there needs to be some
kind of warning information out there
thank you very much there are no further
questions for uh this testifier uh is
nancy sheridan from the public still on
he is not
uh she is one of my constituents she was
on for 602 which brings up a question
are you planning to go back to 602 today
or some other day
it will have to be some other day
because it will have to be announced
fine thank you um
is there anyone else who is from the
public
that
being answered it seems in the negative
i'm going to ask representative marsh
would your pleasure be
to uh move to exec this bill
or in light of
representative canark's statements on
two different items on page two would
you like us just to adjourn this uh
hearing
and execute in a couple of weeks after
more information has come in
well i believe you could execute fairly
soon because representative knurk if his
committee recommends some changes they
sound to me like they would be friendly
amendments and we could just introduce
those after his meeting tomorrow so
i would be content to wait for that i
don't think it necessarily has to wait
for a couple of days i don't see any
urgency towards our passing the spill so
i don't feel we need to execute at this
time okay good thank you that was my
guess but i wanted to give that as a
courtesy to you
with that
i closed the hearing on house bill 163
and we move to
now open the hearing on house bill 240
relative to identification of cannabis
strain for therapeutic cannabis and the
chair recognizes representative casey
conley
thank you mr chairman committee members
i am casey conway state representative
from dover
uh here to introduce hb 240.
this bill would allow therapy excuse me
therapeutic cannabis dispensaries to use
the name of the specific cannabis
strains when dispensing them to clients
these names would be used both inside
those dispensaries to identify uh the
cannabis on the packaging that uh
patients would leave with
um and on dispensary websites when
identifying
uh inventory and so on
what this bill does is fixes an issue in
our therapeutic cannabis rules
that prohibit strain names from being
used like this
currently they are represented by
initials and shorthand
and while that might seem simple enough
it can get confusing quickly
a quick look at the temescal wellness
dispensary in dover last night showed a
healthy assortment of cannabis strains
available
these include something called bdr prj
gba prj or even ac prj
and if those weren't satisfactory
there's bbk
sd plus and srd
and i don't know about you but i have no
idea what any of that really means
um
so as i wrote this testimony last night
i had to constantly refer back to that
website to make sure
each of those were spelled correctly
um it was easy to transpose a letter or
mistyped a letter here and there
and that's the problem is that you know
mistaking a letter or two
uh
with this with this medicine
would mean you would come home with an
entirely different product than you
intended
um these strains have different effects
they provide different relief for
different patients uh but under the
existing rules customers have to rely on
this awkward shorthand
and we can resolve it by passing this
bill when joining uh
near every other state
that allows the actual strange names to
be used including maine um and vermont
so
uh what are these names this is uh
things like northern lights pineapple
express uh these are the actual names of
the strains and in many cases they date
back
50 60 years
they're the same name uh industry-wide
that's not as if it was just sort of
the brainchild of a store manager or
dispensary manager somewhere
and these for cannabis patients these
are just as recognizable as uh things
like lipitor and claritin and privacy
you could pick up at the pharmacy
so i asked you please recommend passage
of this bill it's a streamlining of the
process to very simple
without him happy to take questions i'm
also happy to defer questions
uh to former representative tim
josephson uh who plans to testify later
and was an original sponsor of this bill
uh or others who may testify uh later
but thank you for the opportunity
thank you representative conley the
chair calls on representative woods
thank you mr chair and uh thank you for
taking my question mr conley um i'm i'm
not sure exactly what full name actually
means you made reference to
a quote standardized commercial name but
that's not something that's required uh
in in medicine uh there's an agency
through the ama
uh which has a naming
uh uh criteria that's used and that
becomes the uh like lipitor
uh and other
kinds of names uh that's not the
chemical name i wasn't sure if you meant
a botanical the full name being the
botanical name
um
just a full name may not really
it doesn't seem like that would really
address the issue uh in the sense that
even though it may be quotes
the supposed standard there's nothing
that says that that same strain
um would it would could be used under a
different name
so it it it may be the same in colorado
as it is in temescal here uh new
hampshire but not necessarily required
to have the same name
uh and uh i follow it
uh that is what happens if the um
a particular medication is a compound
with multiple um
agents within that uh how would that be
named
representative thank you
i'm as i indicated and fully
acknowledged i'm not an expert on this
um and rather than uh do my best
to give you correct information i'm
going to defer that question to a
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question i noticed that
in your testimony you said you were
concerned about the fact that currently
these names are prohibited
um and in your
uh bill as it is drafted on line three
you are now going to require the
alternate the the full name of the
cannabis strain
uh did you want to make that mandatory
and use the word chao or would the word
may and leave it to the discretion of
the
dispensers be a
representative thank you uh
i don't feel strongly on this point i
think uh may
um
might be better than chal but um
as you know this is an issue that hangs
up this legislature from time to time so
but i do believe
may is probably preferable
thank you i was just trying to get your
thoughts on whether you were
wanting to mandate it so thank you
representative gay
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question to me
the real issue is not just the name of
the product but the content is there any
reason
why
the
re
all i can think of right now even though
there are over 75 compounds already
identified in various kinds of marijuana
the ones i'm really concerned about of
course are the thc and the cbd is there
any reason why that can't be listed
or mandated because that's the real
issue
do you really want to get high or you
really want to get well
[Laughter]
um representative thank you i uh
at the risk of uh saying what i said
before i'm gonna defer that uh the
represent the former representative uh
is is more versed on this than i
and rather than give the committee
incorrect information i'd rather just
defer that question
thank you very much and seeing no hands
uh i said that before i saw a hand i'm
going to now ask representative tim
josephson to speak because he's been
deferred to on a couple of occasions by
the primary sponsor representative
josephson
i do not see representative josephson in
the list if you are there um it looks
like we have a hell on a josephson
perhaps he is using a different name
shall we give that a
try all right
helena josephson um
that is actually me this is uh tim
josephson
i won't ask
that's my wife that's my wife so i uh my
suspicion switching of switching around
um
uh devices here so got it okay uh thank
you very much mr chair thank you
committee and uh hello to all my uh
former colleagues there my name is tim
josephson former representative here in
the state house and uh this was a bill
that representative conley was kind
enough to shepherd through for me this
session uh for the record i am a card
carrying caregiver for therapeutic
cannabis for three people uh my wife my
mother-in-law and one more person who's
actually a member of the house
so what this bill seeks to do is to
allow the true name the botanical name
of cannabis to be strange to be printed
on the labeling of medication
at the dispensaries in new hampshire if
you're not familiar with strain types of
cannabis it's an agricultural product
and as such has different lineages
you can think of it similarly to like
different varieties of apples gala galas
are different from northern spy
different from macintosh different from
granny smith et cetera et cetera you
know cannabis strains have a wide
variety of difference between them but
the effects are more pronounced than
just being sweeter tartar or better for
your pie or better for applesauce
one website that may be of great use to
you here would be leafly.com that's
l-e-a-f-l-y.com
it details all the different strains
and from their website here's a little
description about the differences uh at
a base level uh marijuana strains are
organized into three primary types
sativa indica and hybrid each type of
strain has unique effects on both the
mind and body for example sativa strains
are uplifting uh they pair well you know
with activities uh physically active uh
for for patients that need that on the
opposite end of the strain spectrum
indica strains are relaxing and can
amplify a deep level of physical
sedation meaning indica is great for
those times for deep sleep for when
patients need that
lastly there are hybrid strains that
fall between the indica and sativas
hybrid strains offer a combination of
both energizing and relaxing effects
perhaps they're great for times when
it's too late for an energizing sativa
or too early for a sedating indica
strain
and so while uh the new hampshire rules
permit the differentiation between
indica sativa and hybrid it effectively
stops there
as representative conley
alluded to the different letters are are
all over the map there you can have a
sativa lh which is different from sativa
sc each doing different things perhaps
lh is good for appetite but sc is good
for energy the hybrid category can be
more confusing since hybrids lean
towards sativa and some lean towards
indica and just having initials can lead
to mix-up as one hybrid might be what
you need in the afternoon because it
helps your chronic pain without giving
you too much energy late in the day but
not enough to make you sleepy
i first became aware of this problem
when my mother-in-law got her cannabis
card she she has you know she has been a
cancer survivor
a transplant recipient and all sorts of
things um and so she shared with me the
labeling system and his confusion of
only allowing initials and not names and
so uh with her getting up there in age
and driving being an issue i became a
caregiver for her while helping her
navigate names and strains it was
definitely confusing uh with the
different initials and i wondered if
this is confusing for me what do you
think it's like for elderly and disabled
people who need their medication
it is confusing for people there's no
other way to say it um you know these
folks like my mother-in-law they're from
a time when cannabis was fully illegal
uh and by having to use code like this
it gives this legitimate medical product
an air of illegitimacy or like shadiness
uh she feels like she's still having to
sneak around to ask me to pick up her
medication when it would be much more
legitimate and concise for her to say i
need some northern lights and i need a
point break instead of saying like hey i
need some stuff you know
why is this medication being censored we
don't do this with the medications we
get in pill form uh can you imagine go
to your you know you have a medicine
cabinet in your house uh go to your go
to your medicine cabinet and imagine all
your pill bottles being blank and now uh
your lipitor is classified as lp prozac
is pz claritin is cl and now you have a
you know uh
a medicine cabinet full of just initials
many people take lots of different types
of medications daily and strains of
cannabis are no different
i spoke with folks at the dispensaries
and when i asked about the naming system
i was told they're not allowed to put
the actual names on containers due to a
rule at dhhs
why would they not be able to say the
actual name i was told it was because of
protecting children
and the true labeling of strain names
would be too tempting for children you
know there are stray names like fruity
pebbles or bubblegum kush but these
strains are named from the lineage of
plants that go back decades and they're
creating each train and as such it's
important to be aware of especially for
patients who are seeking to find
specific strains to treat specific
conditions
if someone needs a strain that helps
with appetite they should be able to
tell that strain comes from a line
lineage that helps that condition
dispensaries did not just pull these
names out of a hat their heirloom
varieties and some old names go back
decades
this is a long established system that
other states have used just fine there's
no reason to censor ourselves among
adults
you know the information is is really if
you look if if uh if any of you are
familiar with what the packaging looks
like at the atcs it's very plain it's
just in text font um you know it's plain
font on a medical package similar to a
pill bottle it's not snazzy packaging
it's it's not attractive labeling it's
not colorful fonts
those things if you're concerned about
children those things are in liquor
stores you know on things like you know
a quick look at the schnapps on the
state liquor store website reveals names
like 99 bananas buttershots burst hot
damn cinnamon luscious pomegranate
pleasure you know if we label our liquor
that we let kids into the liquor store
uh why can't we label our medical
packaging as a plain font you know
kids are not allowed inside of the atc's
you just cannot take children in there
patients are told that you have to
secure your medicine and they do
um the therapeutic cannabis program has
been in effect for several years now any
fears that children would be swayed by a
plane label on a medication container
should be long gone
dispensaries have been very helpful in
producing they do give you a little
strain guide with full names that you
can get in person but what happens if
that patient loses that sheet what
happens when the dispensary gets new
inventory uh clear labeling on packaging
would help in the initial consultation
with the dispensary patients are told
about the requirements to secure their
medication keep it away from children uh
this is more than when you get a
prescription from your doctor uh
patients are very aware of the penalties
for not taking care of their medication
so in conclusion i asked the committee
uh hear the requests of people for
clarity on their medication a
well-informed patient can make the best
decisions for their medical cares and we
should not put up barriers or
information
um and just a few quick uh things and to
refer to uh representative woods this
would not and represent gay's program
questions this is not specifically to
the chemical compounds that are in there
but rather the given botanical names as
you alluded to there represented woods
um you know so like i said northern
lights uh point break things like that
so that's uh
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you representative josephson uh
the chair recognizes recognizes
representative folsom
well thank you mr chair um
thank you for providing your testimony
for us today mr justin it very very
informative
um i am in support of this bill and but
i have a question for you
um i'm referring back to um
the question of representative weber
being a former
legislator do you have a preference
between the may and the show
i think the shell is important for the
packaging
the shell is important to have
the packaging be labeled with the actual
strain name
the may is on the website so that the
dispensaries do have the option to put
it on their website or not
i suspect that they would all put it on
their website if they were allowed to um
again i i suspect if it was may on the
labeling of the package that the
dispensaries would go ahead and label
them if they uh if they were allowed to
choose so uh i i feel that it should be
on there in terms of clarity for patient
use
thank you uh representative nelson
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question how many other states
require
this uh require the names on them
correct
uh how about i don't know of any other
state that requires an abbreviation like
we do um
the only other thing i can come up that
i have seen is that connecticut has an
alternative naming format which is
actually even more confusing so i would
not recommend that um but every other
state that i looked into
i'm not sure about requiring it but they
all allow it how about that
um well how many states did you
follow up excuse me
sorry how many states is to have you
contacted or researched
uh just in my research on looking you
know i looked at maybe 10 10 to 15
different states online
like looking looking through their
information
thank you
recognizes representative woods
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
josephson for taking my question uh um
for for my ease can you direct us to the
rsa
uh or is it rules
uh relative to the uh
uh inability to change the labeling you
you mentioned it would be
yeah it would be in the rules
dhhs rules
okay thank you
yes uh thank you uh mr chairman for
allowing me to
ask this question and uh thank you mr
josephson for
uh taking the question
can you repeat the website that you
mentioned before i
i tried it but uh it told me access was
denied so i don't know if it's uh
something
that uh is temperamental
yeah it's uh
leafly.com l-e-a-f-l-y
dot-com
i'm not sure you know because it is uh
you know for adult use and you know it's
not for kids it asks you are you 21
years or older when you log in i believe
or when you go to it
so it may be blocked by some
but that is the website leeflee.com
thank you that was my misspelling anyway
thank you okay
any further questions for the
[Music]
is there any member of the public i show
no one on my screen
here the real helena josephson
correct
you're recognized to speak
hello can can you hear me yes we can
okay um
thank you uh
thank you members of the committee for
your time and consideration um my name
is helena josephson
and i'm a resident of canaan i'm
speaking as a member of the public and a
registered patient in the therapeutic
cannabis program the changes proposed in
this bill would benefit me as a patient
in multiple ways
along with the medications prescribed by
my rheumatologist and other providers
therapeutic cannabis plays an important
role in the management of my chronic
illness
armed with a prescription from my
rheumatologist i can go to rxlist.com
and learn about side effects and dosing
of things like hydroxychloroquine which
i do take
but not so with therapeutic cannabis i
have my doctor's blessings but i'm on my
own to find strains and delivery methods
that will help me the most
fortunately there's a lot of information
available online and it's only getting
better as more states get on board
the website leafly.com catalogs
thousands of strains like other
agricultural products different
varieties of cannabis have different
effects heritage strains with well-known
effects are crossed with others to
create new strains
so if i search s strains for nerve pain
i might find out that blackberry kush is
a patient favorite but how can i use
that information my dispensaries website
doesn't have anything with that name i
might see bk and pk but what does that
tell me at the dispensary they could
give me a strain key which is literally
a decoder so i can decode the names of
the products on the website and in my
medicine cabinet but that doesn't
actually help me when i'm doing research
at home
through trial and error i've learned
which strains ease my worst symptoms i
have complex medical conditions and some
strains don't help me
i'm also learning more about the various
medicinal components of cannabis like
the cannabinoids and terpenes and as we
get more detailed information i can use
that to choose better medication when i
visit my dispensary it would be so much
more helpful if i could do this research
at home online before i go to pick up my
curbside order
thank you members of the committee for
hearing my testimony and if anybody has
any questions for me i would be happy to
seeing done i'm looking for
representative casey conley i i do not
see him on my list i hope he hasn't
it looks like he has
he has dropped off i was going to give
him the opportunity
uh to give us his pleasure as to whether
we could exact this or should we wait
if he wishes to amend the phrase on line
four full name to botanical name lest
there be any confusion but i don't see
him
and i do have representative conor
wishes to speak i'll give you a few
minutes
no just to inform you that uh
mike holt the therapeutic cannabis
administrator is still on the line if
anybody has any questions for him
i will call uh mike holt back if he
wishes to
address any of the questions on this
particular bill
he has his hand up and i will let him
uh
thank you uh chair um again for the
record my name is michael holt i'm the
administrator of the therapeutic campus
program
um
i don't have any proactive testimony on
this bill i just wanted to make myself
available for questions if uh any of the
committee members had questions of the
of the program it is correct uh the
testimony so far is correct that
administrative rule prohibits the use of
commercial strain names in a public
setting including on websites social
media sites
and on
uh the product labeling
however we do allow those commercial
strain names to be available
in the dispensary and through direct
communication
between the atc and the patients in the
form of that that key that or the legend
that that you've heard about
um
so uh yes it's this is not in law this
is in rule um this bill would uh
certainly supersede our rule prohibition
for the use of commercial strain names
um the department does not have a
position um again on this bill
the rule was
written
based on testimony received from
advocacy groups
that were concerned that commercial
strain names
being publicized on websites and social
media sites would be
attractive to children
um a couple of the names that we heard
today were
uh
of strange names are northern lights um
and point break um
they're
they run they run the gamut um uh and so
we we added that to our rules um i will
offer that we have received significant
amount of pushback from patients and
from the atc's
about that requirement
we've heard the arguments that we've
heard today
numerous times
we do a patient survey every year
and this regulation is a common uh
source of complaint from patients
um
saying that they cannot do their own
research
because they do not know uh the the the
strains that are available so thank you
thank you mr holt um would
the bill on line four when it uses the
term
full
name
mean to you
botanical whatever
would the use of the term full name be
sufficient to strike out that statute or
would a more precise
term be required
the term that
the term that would make the law as
clear as possible would be the term
commercial
straight name
thank you that's the term that we use in
our rules and that's what's understood
when i think of the term botanical i
think of cannabis sativa
as the scientific name
okay thank you uh representative woods
do you have a question for mr
holt uh uh thank you mr chair and thank
you mr holt that you've answered part of
my question already uh just a request it
could
for for ease
of finding it that could you forward us
the rule that currently is in place that
i can give it to you right now if you
like
uh h e
dash c
b is in boy
representative woods your follow-up
no i hope somebody got that
your follow-up is would this be perhaps
emailed to our committee
yes thank you
representative
uh my question thank you mr chairman and
thank you mr holt um my question
i don't know no
my question is
is there any reason you can't put both
names could this specify
both names because commercial names can
change
so
it certainly makes sense to put the
commercial name but how about adding the
uh
the technical
plant name to
with this
there would be no prohibition against uh
what you're suggesting uh if this bill
were to pass
we do require or allow
the atcs
we require them to categorize these
strains into the dominant forms of
indica sativa and hybrid when they are
hybrids so that information is generally
available and it is not restricted by
thank you representative nelson
yes some question on line number seven
the alternative treatment center may
list
to uh
for me no it is not an issue it would
put the question of whether or not the
atc wants to use the commercial strain
name um or not uh the the language may
would allow them to do it my
assumption is that all of the atc's will
choose to reintroduce the commercial
strain names to their labels their
with no further questions from mr holt
the chair recognizes representative
roger dontenville who is a co-sponsor of
the bill
representative
he's having to be promoted to a panelist
because he's using an older form
can you hear me now we can thank you sir
thank you mr chairman uh and thank you
uh fellow committee members
uh
i am that representative that mr
josephson alluded to i am a registered
mar uh cannabis user medical cannabis
user uh
a little background
uh
i have cancer i am in remission but i
have residual effects from my cancer
and
my treatments
i have i have spoken with many
cancer survivors who have found respite
with the use of therapeutic cannabis and
therefore i went i asked my
medical provider if they would pre
if i would qualify
and they were more than happy to sign
off on me because they know what i've
been through
uh
i'm not here to discuss the merits of
medical care uh cannabis other than the
fact that i find great relief in it i am
here to uh
back up the fact that there is confusion
about the labeling of the cannabis that
i use uh there is a myriad of
ways that that cannabis
can be
whether it be in edibles or ointments
or flour
or
a
and what i have found is that the most
descriptive
is one edibles
it lets me know if it's an indica or a
sativa
the problems my residual health problems
are
chronic pain
and
difficulty sleeping at night
where an indica would be
uh highly
indicated at the time
to to use that for for
early evening and going to bed
i'm trying to work my body into getting
back into shape after all the treatments
i've gone through
so i develop hip and leg issues
where
acceptable or
beneficial at that time where i could go
out and walk or swim
however
i have found
the same issues that that uh helena went
through and other folks have gone
through where you really can't track the
strain
to see which one's going to be
beneficial at that certain time
and i think
i was a co-sponsor of the bill because i
and i know information online
kind of directs you indica sativa hybrid
without really getting into the
specifics
and being that it's curbside now
it's not always conducive to going
calling in to the to atc
uh or to
uh going online to try to break down the
specific strains
and knowing that i could read that
online
would save me time
getting the right medication for what my
issue health issues are at the time
so i am in total support and i feel that
as mr josephson has said that the word
shall should be
should be in there
to let people because i am an elder
statesman
if i'm having issues with it i'm sure
that the people who i see in the parking
lot
who are set up to get it are probably
in the ballpark of my age as well
i know they must be going through it as
well
thank you very much
you're very welcome thank you for your
testimony and i'm going to uh ask
uh two things number one uh christina i
see no one else ready to testify is that
correct
that is correct then in that case i
closed the hearing on house bill 240 and
representative
since representative conley i do not see
is still in this meeting
i'm going to ask you to do something
representative
i don't see him either anymore oh well
what i'm going to ask representative
conley then i'm going to send him an
email
is um i'm going to
uh not execute this bill at this time
because i want to give the sponsors the
choice of do you want us to execute as
it exists
or bring an amendment to change
line four to say commercial
and if they wish to do that they
uh can make sure an amendment is got and
we can do it accordingly uh
representative please unmute
sorry
uh because the bill is now in our
possession i think it might be um
helpful if one of us got that um
amendment and
i personally would not vote for the bill
unless it says commercial because we
have been told by mr holtz that that's
the proper term so i will volunteer
to get an amendment that says commercial
and get it to the committee if the
committee decides to
at some point
uh consider that but i will take it on
myself to do that i i appreciate that
that saves me an email to the sponsor
representative canark you may unmute and
speak
yes just to i think what uh uh mr holt
said was the commercial strain name so
the wording would be specifying the
commercial strain
name not just commercial name i think
commercial referred to representative
connor can let representative connect
obtain the uh appropriate thank you
yeah well then in that case folks should
we do the shower of the may for the
first line line three
they wanted the shell so let's let that
answer had to do with on line seven
uh sorry i apologize
i'm wrong yes you're right
yes
yeah
okay now the chair declares us to be
quite hungry and we will come back
at 20 past one have a good lunch
everybody
and if christina you could put out a
sign saying this committee is out to
me
uh
[Music]
mr chairman can you hear me
i can hear you madame
chair emerita
it's okay we can we can dispense with
the
with all of that i just wanted to let
you know that i i got a message that i
have a uh meeting about one of my casa
kiddos that's been rescheduled till 3 30
so i will be stepping away at that point
well the uh
bill in question could go on
for days
well i just wanted to let you know uh
this business of having the power over
here is is very exciting and actually
i think i've done to get the hang of it
so that if ms dyer needs to step away
i
uh if nothing
on
if nothing different from what i've seen
so far comes up i i've got the hang of
it so
yeah
it also does let me
mute people when when they need
it doesn't let me unmute them
unfortunately but
um
i i can only request them to unmute
i had asked christina
if we were going to go forward with that
uh
representative edwards bill
and the 100 plus people who had signed
up to testify in person or verbally
uh still wanted to and i gave them a
minute
could she mute them at one minute and
she said she could um
as it turned out uh the way the thing
proceeded most of them dropped off i can
see them maybe you can too on the
participants i can now on the
participants list yes and and
that when i roll my
um cursor over them i get a a
possibility that i'll i'm allowed to
talk i can promote the panelist and as
she did with the various
uh josephsons she can re you you can
also rename them so that people know
who's speaking
um
which is good to find out because csg
renamed me
on a panel they were running and it took
me about a week to figure out how to put
myself back to the name i prefer to use
well we're learning i'm finding doing
this from home is significantly easier i
was sure you would find that doing it
from home is significantly easier
because you've got a level playing field
and you can see everybody and the
committee size is such that you can see
all of the participants on one screen
yeah
and i can also see uh who
among the attendees wishes to speak and
things like that so i i may wind up if i
come in person
next time
to bring my laptop with me and work off
that
it it you may the only issue you will
find if you do that in the committee
room if other people are doing the same
thing you will have
interference issues because i know when
i was trying to get representative
mckay
installed on zoom
the
issue was when i had my ipad close to
his computer
you can get echoes and uh feedback as
well it was it was very unpleasant
yeah well the solution for that is use
your headset
prepare your headset if your
representative mckay or i had a headset
we would have but of course
for mark if he brings it in does
yeah
and well done uh lucy regarding jim uh
he's on on his own you're not in the
same building with him he did it thank
you for teaching him i haven't well it
wasn't a matter of teaching him it was a
matter of realizing
that uh he uses a proprietary
when you when you email him it's at
mygate.com that is a proprietary
software and hardware
that is designed to be
for elders who don't want to get into
the sorts of things where we push the
wrong button and something happens with
our computer and we never get out of
whatever happened
this one you can't do that and he kept
saying well zoom is installed so when i
went and looked at it
the screen is all purple and white and
it's very large buttons on the screen
and there's a lovely trackball thingy
and
yes up in the corner there is something
that says zoom so i clicked on zoom
and it said 100
and it's the zoom that allows you to
make the already large print even larger
and to install zoom the program
you have to call the nice lady in the
central time zone because they do not
permit third-party installations on
their programs at all but they had to
make an exception for zoom because of
covid because everybody wanted to talk
to their grandchildren
so the nice lady in the central time
zone took an hour and a half wow
who actually installs boom on his
computer and none of us can find zoom
and we will never see the little zoom
blue thingy
but
if he has an email and it says join
click here to join he clicks and he
joins or he clicks and he writes in the
password and join so
uh you can't you can't pull up the
program as we would on a pc or a mac
but the emails take him directly to
where we are so
that all works you know it's amazing
what we got accomplished over lunch fran
went out and had a makeover if you look
it's my understanding that everybody in
the central time zone is nice
uh this lady was incredibly kind
incredibly helpful uh she was
unfortunately working on a computer that
was also quite slow so
we had a great deal of time to chat
but
um it it all worked out well in the end
and
we're good
it's particularly helpful when committee
services sends out the link again one
hour before the program because
otherwise
for jim the
the
emails get lost in the maw of emails
and
i always write down who the email comes
from so i can use the search function
but right i'm not sure the search
function none of the functions on jim's
computer work the same way they do on
our computers right though nobody can
talk in things
without looking at best with with their
coffee or thinking hey we're like we're
it's funny about technology and the
speed of it improving
my wife is 14 and a half years younger
than me
and the other night we were watching tv
and there was a problem and i heard
myself say
that frightens me because you're not
much
we're in the same bracket there yeah
i think mark has a tube going
well she looked at me and made something
akin to what jerry just said
[Laughter]
my husband and i
we married young and when he was in
graduate school i was undergrad we had
an ancient old tv and indeed a tube
would go he made a chart we would
take all the tubes out go down to the
hardware store yeah them all you know
yeah so much fun you could actually fix
your speaking of tubes yeah
i have this cute little radio and behind
me here it's all tubes
oh is it represented i'll just remind
everybody we're still on the live stream
just in case anybody we know yeah don't
say they're too bad
i will still say representative
representative kelsey wiped that smirk
the public knows this is the best
committee in the house yeah jan schmidt
commented about it too isn't that nice
so many people come last year somebody
said look you're all there 21 of you you
know
whoever it was said oftentimes they go
before committees there's five six
people yeah and then they hate each
other i knew it it'll be good when i got
it
who wouldn't show up
i did thank you so much you're so
welcome that was awesome
that is cool can anybody quickly point
me to the way the
they said the calendar
attendees
and they can hear us they can't speak to
us what is the um link to it it's in the
counseling calendar
calendar and they would have to follow
the link in the calendar right what i've
done is just i cop i i copy it and then
i paste it into an email to send them if
they want it but it's sometimes copies
totally weird especially if it's cost a
page break it will copy strange and it
will copy without the line breaks you
have to go back and put them back in
because it goes one two and three so
number three maybe after a passcode so
it looks wrong so you have to go back
and re reformat at least i do i'm a mac
user and that works for you
if you go
if you put in the
the bill number
on the search thing it will give you a
brief description in the description it
will have the zoom link
right the question is how you get that
to somebody else so if they can do it
when you cut and paste it reformats into
a less helpful form
right
to answer a private
communication from representative marsh
to me i do not represent the 12th essex
county of massachusetts district however
well in walpole i'm i i could
practically spit into vermont so
it was interesting this morning as i
watched the plow
plowing representative knurk's
street
oh you can see that
behind you
is a glass
framed something and it reflects out
your window
yeah i was watching what looks like a
front end loader and back and forth down
your street yeah i see where you could
see that oh boy i'd be careful yeah well
i had to go out early this morning and
shovel it away from the garage so we can
pull it up pull it out and then also uh
scrape off the heavy snow off the solar
panels so it won't slough after it gets
done and leaving me another big pile
yeah jeffrey
is is is that a portrait of you behind
you
yes
oh okay move your head move your head
yeah no i i
it's very special
i'd love to get a good look at it
sometime sometime i had a dear
friend and colleague at unh who was a
painter
and he wanted a model and he asked if i
would model
and he painted it and when i he showed
it at an art show and i bought it i
could not find it it wasn't professor
hatch was it
no it was um
oh god uh roger beatty and there's a
long story roger and i grew up in the
same neighborhood in boston
we were contemporaries we went to the
same schools we were both and i am only
trusting that representative weber is
listening closely
we were both graduates of tufts
university
um and known as jumbos
and capable of singing the uh various
this is fun but we should get to work
it's 119. the public is waiting for us
and uh absolutely the final word about
toss williams beat you for 30 years in a
row until recently and tufts has been
beating williams in football and there's
something wrong about that
um you aren't going to believe this
representative but i have my freshman
i open the hearing on house bill 185
removing the work requirement of the new
hampshire granite advantage health care
program the chair recognizes the primary
sponsor representative shapiro would you
present your bill please
thank you mr chairman and
hello to all my colleagues
i am representative joe shapiro cheshire
16 keane
i come before you today to introduce
house bill 185 fn a bill that will
repeal the work slash community
engagement requirement for the granite
advantage health care plan more
frequently known as expanded medicaid
while the work requirement is yet to be
implemented it should be noted that it
remains in statute and efforts to make
it a reality continue to be pursued in
court
the work requirement first came
to be when a compromise was reached in
2017.
expanded medicaid would be renewed for
an additional five years and a program
to ready recipients for work and
discourage long-term reliance on state
benefits would be embedded in the law
requiring 25 hours of work and or
community engagement made it the most
extensive requirement in the country
i fully understand that this was a good
faith bargain made by democrats and
republicans allowing both sides to
fulfill their priorities
in the mean in the intervening years
however the landscape has changed
dramatically and the work requirement is
no longer viable
therefore it is time in my opinion to
repeal this segment of the law
since being into since being signed into
law the following have occurred
arkansas put a similar program with less
required hours into effect in 2018
causing some 18 000 beneficiaries to
lose their medicaid benefits
in 2019 new hampshire attempted to roll
out its program but it had to call a
halt to its efforts when it was unable
to enroll twenty thousand of the fifty
thousand recipients
subject to the requirement
according to the u.s government and
accountability office
that effort and implementation failed in
spite of expenditures of 4.4 million
dollars 187
000 of those dollars in state funds and
the rest in federal monies
a federal court ruled that the arkansas
program was not lawful
in july 2019 the u.s district court for
the district of columbia
ruled that the new hampshire program was
invalid saying that providing medical
care to the needy is the medi is
medicaid's core objective and that the
federal waiver to
fail to adequately consider the work
requirements effects on medicaid
coverage
in other words medicaid is designed to
provide health care not job readiness or
character building
in response to an appeal the dc circuit
court of appeals ruled once again in
february 2020 that the u.s
health and human services lacked
authority to approve the arkansas
program
since the arkansas and new hampshire
programs are essentially the same new
hampshire joined with arkansas and the
trump administration to appeal to the
u.s supreme court
two months ago the supreme court agreed
to hear the case and presumably a
if an effort to
if an
if an effective work requirement was
ever practical it is clear that covet 19
has now created many new obstacles
having people lose their insurance
during a pandemic is unwise and
ethically unquote ethically questionable
and requiring more people to engage in
work and or volunteering will serve to
heighten the current public health
crisis
it is time in my opinion to repeal the
granite advantage health care program
work requirement
this was a program conceived in good
faith by democrats and republicans with
different philos philosophical points of
view
which has proved to be unworkable
practically
legally and now from a public health
standpoint
standpoint as well
at this point repealing this segment of
rsa 126 a a will merely align
new hampshire's statute with the federal
reality
thank you and i am willing to take
questions
hearing
no questions uh the chair
is looking for the list of who is up
and i don't really have
that from
[Music]
house committee services
um
i'm going out with that
thank you
of course you can
we do have um henry lippman from dhhs on
the list
mr lipman please come forward and
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee
here on an informational basis today
in terms of adding to what
representative shapiro
outlined for you um
last night it came across that the
supreme court is
expecting oral arguments in this case on
march 29th
and
you know it is in in litigation and i'm
basically here to answer any questions
that the committee might have on
the requirement or kind of where we
i'll add one other thing just in terms
of the
the pandemic
that in the public health emergency
period um
states who are accepting an enhanced
fmap percentage would not have the um
ability to drop
people from from coverage that's just a
um
just an expansion in terms of what was
outlined about the concern of the public
health emergency
that if we were in that
being in that period the
um
you know
all 50 states and territories to my
understanding have accepted um the
maintenance of effort requirements and
we're not permitted during that period
to
drop people from coverage
hello everyone can you hear me
yes
yeah i don't like this cell phone thing
it's harder to know whether you're
connected or not uh thank you mr
chairman for taking my question and
thank you henry for appearing before us
my question regards the pending
litigation would that litigation become
moot and therefore we would save the new
hampshire uh the state of new hampshire
money or this bill to be signed into law
thank you for your question
i think that
if the supreme court were to find that
the secretary of health and human
services especially had
had the
the if you will the authority to
implement this
we would have to go through a process of
applying for another
um
waiver
because the the current one wouldn't
automatically go back into effect to my
understanding
thank you very much
saying none the chair recognizes don
mckinney from new hampshire legal
assistance
good afternoon this is don mckinney
i'm the policy director at new hampshire
legal assistance can you hear me we can
okay thank you
i feel like i i will be brief and i
thought representative shapiro's
overview was excellent and um i just
wanted to to kind of
share our our thinking with you on this
we support hb 185 to remove the work
requirement from granite advantage new
hampshire legal assistance has
consistently opposed the medicaid work
requirement because it is contrary to
federal law
medicaid is a healthcare program not a
work program people need healthcare to
stay healthy so they can work not the
other way around
in fact two-thirds of those on granite
advantage are in working households
that is why our organization fought this
in federal court
and if the work requirement wasn't
halted in august of 2019 nearly 17 000
new hampshire residents would have lost
health coverage
this is despite the significant efforts
on the part of
the department of health and human
services to inform people and the
previously mentioned four million
dollars
spent by the state to implement the
program
while this was prior to covid the
pandemic reminds us of how important
healthcare is not just to individuals
and families but to the public health of
our communities
likewise the resulting economic fallout
is a reminder of how uncertain work is
for those who rely on medicaid as a
safety net we urge the new hampshire
legislature to pass this bill removing
the work requirement to provide granite
seeing no questions thank you miss
mckinney for your testimony
thank you
i have no other names um christina are
there names that you have that have
asked to speak
any further discussion from within the
committee
i really expected to be here till five
o'clock this afternoon
representative weber told me that there
would be days like this and they're
usually monday through sunday so uh
with that
i closed the hearing on house bill 185
fn
you've been a good audience and you can
now go out and play
what this chair
yeah
what about executing that bill we just
heard there's nothing that has to be
worked on
well there are some that some of the
people in the room here are
telling me that they would like to wait
a little bit to see how the arguments go
before the supreme court
we have to decide long before that don't
we didn't say march 29
we have to act before that though we do
yeah
and we will
i i
i'd just like to
chime in and say i think
we've had a very intense couple of days
and perhaps letting the dust settle on
everything at this point
might
be helpful
um and and i just want to thank
the chairman again because this is not
easy and
um
much much as i am sorry that the timing
didn't work out as you had expected i'm
glad it's not just me who has days like
this because
i certainly had my share of them where
uh people were either sitting and
waiting for the next hearing forever or
i was apologizing to people for having
over scheduled so my turn
representative marsh
yes uh thank you and in response to
representative kenner's question uh i
personally am happy that we aren't
voting at this time because i don't want
to address the issue as to whether i'm
going to be allowed to vote over a cell
phone when you can't see the whites of
my eyes are not so therefore i would be
very happy to wait until my internet
comes back up
we can see the whites of your receiver
i was i was schooled by by our wonderful
house clerk that i needed to see your
face on any vote
so that's why i keep looking at my
screen when i'm doing the votes because
i'm looking to find you which little box
you're right
by the way i want to just check
representative march did you actually
call in on the dial-in number or did you
use your phone and use the zoom app
i called in on the dial-in number and in
fact i had to
text christine how to do that because i
didn't think that this would ever happen
and uh to lose my landline and my
internet at the same time in the middle
of the hearing when i didn't build the
reason it up is i've done a zoom on my
phone
and if actually you have your zoom app
on the phone you can actually go to the
meeting through zoom yes and when you go
to the meetings you zoom you are
visualized
only if you have the meeting link though
yeah well
i i would have that in my emails but it
never occurred to me to install it on my
phone because i hate doing things on my
phone because the screen isn't big
enough and i can't see it and i like to
do things on my little tablet so
i i will consider that yeah it's a good
idea everybody to have a backup during
this time
uh conceivably because this may happen
again with power outages or this or that
and so yeah you can download the app
it's not what you want but i've done it
representative
you are a retired eye surgeon do
something about your eyes so you can see
it
and yet you were willing to have me have
my procedure on a committee table
last year
you likely would have done very well
well yeah and we were all the
psychologists and counselors around
there to do the after action
thing that the trauma is
causing yeah thanks
yeah they were all fighting over who
would get to hold your hand
well that's that's representative woods
of course are we still in a public
session or is okay
that's what i was going to say we're
still we're still alive
well that's why they tune into this
channel a representative cannon that's
what i was going to say i'm all set now
we're live we're just we're just fun
people
yeah it could be saturday night live we
this is the comedy relief you know we've
been talking about cannabis all day
well you know i i would point out the
masterful restraint from this committee
that when we looked at the cannabis bill
in some detail nobody used the phrase
wait for it we're going down into the
weeds
well that's right i was sent a text at
the court of the day is me saying quote
minimizing the side effect of euphoria
end quote and i do have to agree that
usually euphoria is not a side effect
but here it actually is because it's not
for your improvement
um i
you probably know that it's my habit
when we have a bill that i go out and do
i do my own research so on the
telemedicine bill
i went to
every therapist that i knew who was not
on the committee to ask them what they
felt about
doing this over telemedicine
and what i learned was that if you are a
patient
territory here folks
no it's okay
and if you lay all the therapists in the
state
end to end
you will still not reach a conclusion
unless the patient wants to find
[Laughter]
i'll meet you
i'll meet you halfway maybe a kansas
easy
is that where you're from
that is
oh
go mahomes
go kansas
central time zone again we talked about
the central time zone earlier
everybody in the central time zone is
sweet
well we're at least friendly
yep yes and see i could move from texas
to live free or die because that really
i thought it was live free or kill
let's not go there
nikki that is a cute dog
oh thank you i have two of them
they're
where are they i don't know do they
count as votes
what what's behind you not in this state
are they are they still in here oh yeah
oh
oh look at dog webber oh
look at dog webber that's my personal
assistant
yeah you know it was fun yesterday you
probably overheard when heidi kroll was
testifying her son kept making some
noise in the background and when i had a
zoom meeting with her just a couple of
weeks ago you know we were trying to get
some work done and he was hopping on her
lap and stuff like that and again it's
so much fun to see people's dogs
that kind of stuff but i felt bad for
her try to testify on a bill and the kid
is making noise in the background
uh mr chairman uh i just a cyber are we
done uh my daughter just called and she
has a snowblower problem which she would
like some help with
i think i i think we're done i'm just
taking things up with my skeleton crew
and
i think definitely